[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très content d'être avec
vous ce soir de timmins à en avoir en
passant par sudbury windsor ya des
millions d'électeurs qui sont allés
voter aujourd'hui en ontario le point
culminant d'une courte campagne
électorale à peine 28 jours mais d'une
très longue précampagne les élections
étant à date fixe on a l'impression que
l'ontario est plongé en mode électoral
depuis déjà plusieurs mois les annonces
et les premières se sont multipliés pour
tenter de séduire la population
c'est maintenant aux électeurs de
trancher est ce que le premier ministre
sortant d'oxford sera réélu pour un
deuxième mandat qui va former
l'opposition officielle
on a bien de répondre à toutes ces
questions l'autre vous présenter les
résultats qui devraient commencer à
arriver très rapidement après 21h je
vous présente toute l'équipe qui va vous
accompagner tout au long de cette soirée
que vous nous suiviez à la télé à la
radio ou encore sur le web à mes côtés
sur le plateau natacha mcdonald's dupuis
correspondante parlementaire geneviève
tellier professeur à l'école d'études
politiques à l'université d'ottawa
bonsoir à vous deux mois sera philippe
de montigny qui va animer ce soir notre
carte interactive des résultats oui
bonsoir au filet puis voire de la
couleur dans votre environnement de
travail est bienvenu cinq gars qui sera
en charge lui de suivre les courses
serrées et les élus aux quatre coins de
la province bonsoir bienvenue françois
mathieu je commence avec un premier tour
de table rapide vous aller surveiller
quoi ce soir bienvenus d'abord oui alors
ce qu'on surveille ce soir c'est
vraiment le chiffre 63 c'est le chiffre
magique le chiffre de la majorité en
ontario à l'assemblée législative il ya
124 sièges au total la moitié donc c'est
60 de plus un ça fait 60 3 c'est le
nombre de sièges donc un parti doit
obtenir pour pouvoir gouverner son
devoir compter sur l'appui d'un autre
parti les progressistes conservateurs y
était arrivé en 2018 que se passera-t-il
ce soir c'est vraiment la grande
question et on sera là évidemment pour
vous présenter les résultats à mesure
qu'ils ne parviendront oui elle beaucoup
de chefs que vous allez voir et entendre
ce soir 63 c'est définitivement un 1 de
ce qu'il faudra retenir de près natacha
geneviève vous gardez vos yeux sur quoi
ce soir là bas est ce que d'oxford va
réussir à s'accrocher à sa majorité et
est-ce qu'il va venir accroître son
nombre de sièges si c'est le cas qui va
remporter remporter la course pour la
seconde place donc qui va former
l'opposition officielle et quel chef va
être en danger ce soir après qu'on ait
reçu les résultats pour ma part aussi qu
d'oxford beaucoup travaillé pour aller
chercher des nouveaux comptes et des
comptes et qui était dû surtout par le
npd on parle du sud de l'ontario où on
parle d'un mille du niagara ont quand
même du nord avec le secteur minier est
ce que ça va porter fruit est ce que la
stratégie de doc fois de ne pas trop
regarder le grand toronto mais d'aller
plus dans ces secteurs l'avons rapporté
dans votre savoir ce soir oui monsieur x
qui est un des chefs que le moins voyagé
durant la province campagne peut un peu
plus tranquilles ils ont filé pour ceux
à la maison qui veulent suivre en
particulier une ou deux ou trois
circonscriptions c'est possible de faire
ça tout personnaliser vous vous rendez
aux radios de radio
canada.ca barres obliques résultats au
pluriel et sur ce tableau de bord là
vous pouvez vraiment personnaliser
l'expérience à mesure que les résultats
rampe pouvait choisir ici vos
circonscriptions favorite la vôtre celle
qui vous intéressent les courses c'est
rire vos groupon vous propose également
une série de sa conscription
intéressantes notamment celle des chefs
de partis donc cette accusation la est
disponible sur votre téléphone sont vos
tablettes et sur le site internet petit
conseil d'ami à l'isie plus tôt que tard
parce qu'on nous dit qu on nous avertit
que les résultats à partir de 21h ça
vaut des bulles est extrêmement rapide
va très très vite alors c'est le moment
de faire ce maintenant avant les
résultats dans une vingtaine de minutes
il ya beaucoup de monde qui ont voté
aujourd'hui mais il ya des gens qui
avaient déjà voté avant la journée
d'aujourd'hui par anticipation c'est à
peu près 1 millions d'ontariens ça
représente à peu près 10% des électeurs
inscrits c'est pas mal plus qu'en 2018
faut savoir par contre élections ontario
avait doublé le nombre de journées de
vote par anticipation justement pour
essayer de stimuler le taux
participation et avait dix jours de vote
par anticipation cette année aussi aussi
2018 savez une élection marquée par le
changement de taux participation avait
atteint presque 57 % ça c'était un
sommet depuis les années 90 à quoi ça va
ressembler ce soir on va garder un oeil
là-dessus sur la participation des
ontariens alors trouver justement notre
collègue andré hahn williams zaki dans
la circonscription d'un vendre 8 bridge
les bureaux de vote sont encore ouverts
pour 25 minutes andréanne que vous
disent les électeurs sur le terrain
nous y faisons beaucoup de choses en
fait premièrement que ça se passe très
bien il peut vraiment de temps
d'attendre beaucoup de gens là qui
continuent à affluer vers le bureau de
vote pour venir voter le responsable du
bureau de vote mode dit que ça a été
comme ça toute la journée que beaucoup
de gens mais pas de temps d'attentes un
petit pépin technique au niveau de la
comptabilisation des votes électroniques
mais tout ça a été réglé très rapidement
et ça ne pas affecter le processus de
vote pour les électeurs des électeurs
d'ailleurs à qui j'ai eu la chance de
parler et m'ont dit que c'était très
satisfait du processus de vote et ils
m'ont parlé des enjeux qui leur tiennent
à coeur d'abord évidemment le coût de la
vie l'augmentation du coût de la vie et
la crise immobilière mais aussi la santé
l'éducation et la sécurité à toronto et
certains m'ont dit qu'ils avaient décidé
cette année de voter pour un nouveau
candidat parce qu'ils veulent du
changement en ontario voyez vous il ya
quand même une certaine volonté de
changement malgré tout chez certains
électeurs vous avez visité des bureaux
de vote aussi dans d'autres
circonscriptions un portrait un peu plus
provincial est ce que c'est la même
chose partout
oui je me suis promené à toronto centre
et aspects des meneurs forte york d'où
se dérouler très bien dans les bureaux
de vote où je suis allée ou qu'un temps
d'attentes les gens pouvaient voter en
seulement quelques minutes et tout le
monde était très satisfait du
déroulement de la journée je vous invite
à écouter quelques électeurs avec qui
j'ai parlé
c'est moi
c'était très bien
[Musique]
alors voila merci beaucoup adrian
williams sur le terrain d'envol
woodbridge ce soir désolé pour le petit
délai de communication
cela dit quelques enjeux avec le vote ce
matin en trop des gens qui ont dû
changer de bureau de scrutin certains
défis avec les systèmes informatiques
c'est ce qu'on nous dit des bureaux de
vote ont dû utiliser le vote par papier
mais ça ne devrait pas affecter la
comptabilité des résultats cela dit il
ya quelques bureaux de vote à certains
endroits notamment qui vont rester
ouverts au delà de 21h parce que
justement ces problèmes là ce matin nos
équipes ont accompagné les chiffres sur
le terrain tout au long de cette
campagne électorale on va retrouver
maintenant matthieu simard au quartier
général du parti progressiste
conservateur à etobicoke ami guy roy
avec le npd à hamilton catherine
brulotte et à woodbridge au nord de
toronto chez les libéraux camif et
résine avec une partie vers à goualich
l'astuce teavaro commence à me tourner
avec vous une campagne pratiquement sans
histoire pour les conservateurs il ya
très peu de choses là qui ont changé
depuis quatre semaines pour d'autres
formes
ouais voilà les
progressistes-conservateurs ont amorcé
la campagne électorale en tant que
meneur en tant que favori et ils ont
conservé cette position au cours des
quatre dernières semaines pour avoir
parlé aujourd'hui à des stratèges à des
gens dans l'entourage de d'oxford les
progressistes conservateurs sont très
confiants ce soir de remporter une
majorité de décrocher un autre
gouvernement et il espère obtenir bon
autant de sièges sinon plus qu'en 2018
pour montrer mathieu quel point on est
confiant ici je pense que mon caméraman
peux vous le montrez on a déjà accroché
les ballons les ballons de la victoire
au plafond ils sont suspendus et on va
les laisser tomber pour le discours de
la victoire de d'oxford un peu plus tard
ce soir donc ça vous prouve à quel point
il ya beaucoup de confiance ou ici au
quartier général des progressistes
conservateurs
pour ce qui est de la campagne qu'on a
affaire ici ben c'est une campagne tout
en contrôle une campagne très
disciplinés ça nous a pas donné donné
droit à des moments marquants je vous
dirais donc que de rester très en
contrôle et il n'y a pas eu de
soubresauts il n'y a pas eu non plus
d'imprévus et ça c'est tout en contraste
avec le doc trop de 2018 2019 alors que
sa popularité était au plus bas avait
atteint un creux rappelez vous il y
avait souvent des scandales avec
d'autres fois il y avait aussi des
décisions très impopulaire de décision
de dernière minute ou encore des volte
face et plus la pandémie en est arrivé
là crever 19 à donner un nouveau souffle
à son gouvernement et ça lui a permis
aussi de présenter une autre facette de
sa personnalité
une autre facette de sa personnalité qui
lui à ski qui lui a servi la pandera
campagne électorale d'ailleurs je vous
propose de regarder le
[Musique]
donc faut d'abord sa campagne sur un
chantier de construction
un premier arrêt qui devient rapidement
la norme
machinerie lourde manipulation d'outils
le chef ce exhibe fièrement partout où
il passe
la stratégie de réélection de d'oxford
est on ne peut plus clair on mise ici
sur les infrastructures les
progressistes-conservateurs ont horreur
du surplace ils promettent des grands
chantiers qui stimuleront l'économie un
message que d'autres fois de martel aux
quatre coins de la province
la campagne est très discipliné l'axé
accordée au journaliste est restreint
donc faut y jouent de prudence son
équipe veut éviter de glisser alors que
le chef est largement favori
donc fondre sarr indemme après le
périlleux exercice du débat télévisé
même s'il admet que son gouvernement n'a
pas été parfait pendant la pandémie
heureusement pour lui le coût de la vie
préoccupe davantage des électeurs que la
copie 19 à ce point-ci
au fil de la campagne de paul ii reçoit
des appuis de taille plusieurs syndicats
associés à la construction se range
derrière lui même chose pour des mers
bien en vue
al'approche du scrutin donc faute pousse
l'audace jusqu'à faire campagne en
territoire néo démocrates
il multiplie les visites à hamilton et
windsor habituellement la chasse gardée
d'un genre vat
en 2018 et progressiste conservateur
avait décroché la victoire en dépit d'un
dock froide inexpérimentés et maladroit
cette fois ci c'est avec un chef plus
aguerri qu'il semble se diriger vers un
deuxième mandat
d'oxford donc est allé visiter hamilton
dans les derniers jours de cette
campagne c'est là que se trouve un
qu'amaigri roy camille la fin d'une
campagne électorale rempli d'embûches
pour la chef andry avat
oui absolument et notamment la coved 19
qui est venu chambouler cette campagne
pour madame horvat parce qu'elle a
contracté le virus et donc elle a dû
passer plusieurs jours en isolement mais
je vous dirais que madame horvat est
revenu après avec un certain regain
d'énergie et d'ailleurs vous voyez au
fond de la salle derrière moi son
autobus de campagne qui dans les
derniers jours de la campagne a parcouru
vraiment beaucoup de kilomètres on a
senti que madame en fait je voulais
pousser cette tournée jusqu'au bout
alors la chef qui est allé voter ce
matin dans son comté de benton centre
elle vint regarder les résultats ce soir
dans une chambre d'hôtel juste à côté du
centre de congrès où je me trouve et
ensuite elle va venir retrouver ses
partisans ici notamment pour son
discours faut dire que c'est une soirée
importante pour madame horvath parce que
manifestement c'est son avenir en tant
que chef du npd qui se joue ce soir il
ya beaucoup d'observateurs qui ont du
mal en fait à imaginer qu'elle reste à
la direction de ce parti s'ils sont si
en fait elle ne devient pas première
ministre et même si elle n'arrive pas à
améliorer son score de 2018 alors
beaucoup d'enjeu en godet gros enjeu
pour madame horvat ce soir en attendant
voici le résumé de sa campagne quand
vous a préparé
on peut dire qu'en dreyer 21 une vieille
routière des campagnes électorales
c'est sa quatrième comme chef du npd
mais aussi sa première en tant que chef
sortante de l'opposition officielle le
statut sur lequel elle tente de jouer le
npd veut se présenter comme le véritable
contre-pouvoir
l'alternative après quatre ans où les
progressistes conservateurs et quinze
années libéral est un matin pipolitique
baup
dans cette campagne le npd mis sur de
grands programmes sociaux accès
universel aux services de santé mentale
assurance dentaire pour les moins nantis
ça coûte beaucoup de
démocrates des libéraux
plusieurs de leurs promesses en santé en
éducation se recoupent dans les sondages
madame horvat se laisse distancer par
stephen del duca ou débat télévisé des
chefs elle peine à se démarquer
quelques jours après un est prévue au
programme andré horvat à trept lakovic
la chef doit reporter un voyage à
travers le nord de la province remplacé
par des apparitions virtuel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ce temps son homologue fédéral
jack médecine vient donner un coup de
pouce pour appuyer les candidats sur le
terrain
après sa période d'isolement andriat or
votre part en tournée mais la malchance
continue de s'abattre sur le npd son
voyage dans le nord est à nouveau
annuler cette fois à cause d'un bris
mécanique des doubles et commerçants
peuvent
être continuera de sillonner le sud et
l'est de la province pour se battre
jusqu'au bout car si peut-être son
dernier tour de piste
température
alors des images du chef libéral ce soir
steven del duca qui arrivent pour
regarder les résultats de cette soirée
électorale avec sa femme et ses deux
filles katherine soir est déterminante
pour lui et pour son parti
vous avez entendu les questions à son
arrivée un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui sur
son siège sur la possibilité pour lui de
l'emporter ici dans votre budget parce
que c'est loin d'être déterminée
évidemment il ya le candidat
conservateur le défilé sort terme à
cause du boulot qui est là qui l'avait
emporté dans cette vague bleue en 2018
mais en plus de sièges évidemment il ya
tout l'enjeu pour le chef libéral de
s'être fait connaître au cours de cette
campagne de 30 jours une en juin portant
puisqu'il est le seul qui en est à sa
première course comme leader d'un parti
il faut dire qu'ici l'ambiance en ce
moment est un peu on sent la nervosité
des alpes et certains organisateurs qui
sont là depuis assez tous les invités
commencent à arriver tranquillement
également mais les organisateurs nous
parle entre autres de retards potentiels
dans les voiles mans de résultats de
deux problèmes qui auraient eu dans
certaines cette construction bref on
regarde beaucoup ce qui se passe et on
voit que les gens s'intéressent
s'inquiète pour le dévoilement des
résultats qui approche dans quelques
minutes à peine et en attendant on sait
comme vous l'avez dit que le chef
libéral écoute lui le dévoilement des
résultats ici dans une salle tout près
d'eux aura lieu la rencontre
éventuellement son discours on nous dit
que c'est possible également qui ne
répondent pas aux questions des médias
ce soir selon comment tout ça va se
produire vous invite à voir comment ces
l'hérault se sont déroulées ces 30 jours
de campagne
contrairement à ses trois opposants
steve del duca en est à sa toute
première campagne électorale à la tête
d'un parti
le chef libéral entre dans la course en
quête d'une double visibilité celle pour
les propositions d'un parti relégué à la
troisième position à queen's park est
celle d'un chef dont l'ascension a été
étouffée par la tendinite que 8,19
des lancement de la campagne électorale
le chef libéral tente de s'imposer comme
interne active aux conservateurs de dog
pound
il reprend un slogan popularisé par les
conservateurs en 2018
cette fois ce n'est pas une bière pour
un dollar mais bien un billet de
transport en commun le chef libéral
propose aussi des investissements en
santé dans les soins de longue durée et
en santé mentale
plusieurs propositions libérales en
environnement sur le logement et en
éducation s'approche de celle des néo
démocrates
lors des débats stephen deroux caf est
assez bonne figure
néanmoins la campagne est loin d'avoir
été tout repos quatre candidats ont dû
quitter la course dans la controverse
rien n'a semblé non plus ébranlé la
vence occupée par les progressistes
conservateurs dans les intentions de
vote
les stratèges conservateurs croient même
que steven del duca pourrait perdre son
siège dans sa circonscription
on va vous montrer des images captées il
ya quelques instants non on me dit qu'on
avait andrea hors vente qui se préparait
à regarder la soirée électorale vous
présenter ça lorsque ça va entrer on va
les trouver qu'à me faire et zen
maintenant du côté du parti vers l'hiver
qui vont tenter d'agrandir leur caucus
ce soir vous êtes ma golf la sacrant
script sens du chef michael qui brigue
un deuxième mandat
et l'ambiance commence à devenir fébrile
ici vous le voyez ça s'installe
lentement mais sûrement il ya une
organisatrice qui vient de prendre la
parole ici on n'attend plus que le chef
des verts max steiner max steiner qui a
passé sa journée dans sa circonscription
avec ses bénévoles où il a tenté une
dernière fois de galvaniser les
électeurs en ce jour de scrutin il a lui
même voté à 10 heures max steiner qui va
tenter de se faire réélire dans cette
circonscription qu'il a remportée en
2018 et à ce moment là ça va être un
moment historique mais tu es devenu le
premier député vert à se faire élire et
a siégé à l'assemblée législative de
l'ontario ce soir on va essayer non
seulement de réitérer l'expérience mais
aussi qu'à grandir son caucus un mot qui
l'a souvent répété dans cette campagne
max steiner c'était momemtum on pourrait
le qualifier par inspiration
dynamisme que selon lui son parti à dans
une circonscription en particulier c'est
parry sound muskoka où il espère bien
faire élire son candidat vedette et il
n'y a pas de candidat libéral c'est
cette année dans cette circonscription
donc il espère bien pouvoir remporter ce
siège d'un bénévole m'a dit un peu plus
tôt on va vraiment garder un oeil ce
soir sur golf parry sound muskoka ou et
bureaux de vote for ferme à 9h30 et
ensuite le chef des verts devrait
prendre la parole mike schreiner qui
s'est aussi fait remarquer durant cette
campagne parce qu'il a été pour la
première fois invités à participer au
débat des chefs on peut écouter le
résumé de cette campagne assez
particulière pour le chat br
politiciens sympathique au ton convivial
mais pointue et terre à terre mike
schreiner a donné une campagne à son
image aux petits moyens petite équipe et
voitures électriques pour rester dans le
sillage de sa plateforme climatique sans
oublier de lancer régulièrement des pics
au premier ministre sortant
la crise du logement le transport
durable et la santé mentale ont aussi
été au coeur de sa campagne
premier verre à siéger à queen's park il
y a quatre ans il vante régulièrement
l'influent ce qu'il a pu avoir dans les
décisions politiques pour une faute de
premier chef des verts à participer à un
débat électoral provinciales en ontario
après sa fougueuse performance le chef a
voulu poursuivre sur sa lancée près à
galvaniser les électeurs
notamment à paris sans de muskoka auprès
de son candidat vedette matt richter un
enseignant bien connu dans la communauté
on met aussi dans la circonscription
university rossdale ou la candidate
n'est nul autre que l'ancien commissaire
à l'environnement diane sachs le pari
est plus ardu mais mike schreiner y
croit
la campagne sur le terrain a toutefois
dû être brusquement interrompue mike
schreiner ayant contracté lakovic 19
le chef de l'opposition de
l'île-du-prince-édouard peter b van
baker a été appelé en renfort pour
montrer l'exemple de sa province un
parti vert peut créer le changement
scrutin un changement que mike schreiner
espère entreprendre avec un caucus a
grandi
les voici donc ces images dans des
grottes la chef du npd qui se prépare à
regarder cette soirée électorale elle
est dans un hôtel juste côté du centre
des congrès de hamilton est un pays rené
convives ont le reportage du chef du
parti vert manama aurait aussi
rappelez-vous qui a contracté la copie
durant la campagne comme quoi la
pandémie pour tout à fait derrière nous
ça peut même faire des petites jambes
est comme ça des policiers en pleine
campagne électorale déjà que c'est pas
long à un mois lorsqu'on est immobilisé
à la maison une semaine disons que c'est
du temps perdu malheureusement pour eux
on va jeter un coup d'oeil philippe à la
répartition des sièges enfants parce que
le parti de doc louis était très solide
il ya quatre ans mais ont perdu car même
pas mal de plumes depuis au moins neuf
députés pour être exact le parti de
d'oxford qui est passé donc de 76 à 67
députés au cours des quatre dernières
années vous allez pouvoir le voir à ceux
à l'écran le sur ce tableau 9 défection
effectivement qu'il conçoit quitter
volontairement le caucus consommateurs
où qu'ils ont été carrément expulsé la
plupart en raison de leur opposition aux
mesures sanitaires du gouvernement
opposition qu'il dont certains expriment
est quand même assez ouvertement donc
allons voir leur du côté des
progressistes conservateurs
il ya bien sûr la députée amanda simard
dans prescott grâce aux ja claqué la
porte au parti progressiste conservateur
dans la foulée des coupes en
francophonie on se rappelle bien de ce
jeudi noir ou le gouvernement faudrait
sabrer le financement de l'université de
l'ontario français avait transféré les
responsabilités du commissariat aux
services en français
sous le joug de l'ombudsman on a
également vu d'autres députés se joindre
dès d'autres de nouveaux partis de
droite notamment belinda carayos dans
cambridge ac qui a cofondé le nouveau
parti bleu qui se veut une alternative
aux progressistes-conservateurs il ya
également riche nécrose qui s'est joint
à lui au parti au parti en ontario lui
qui dans une circonscription du
sud-ouest de l'ontario les autres sont
devenus indépendants et je suis aussi
deux ministres qui ont démissionné de
leurs sièges leur poste de ministres
avant la dissolution à coup beaucoup de
gens qui ne se représente pas dans cette
campagne électorale des départs aussi
chez les partis d'opposition philippe
oui du côté du nouveau parti
démocratique l'opposition officielle on
a perdu deux députés sur l'e40 il avait
été élu en 2018 il ya bien sûr à prendre
mais l'heure dans la circonscription de
l'est
qui a été expulsé exclu du caucus
néo-démocrate en raison d'avoir adhéré à
un groupe facebook qui avait des propos
islamophobes bien en fait il a lancé une
poursuite contre le parti il se présente
ce soir comme indépendants il ya
également les baigneurs dcti n'a pas
réussi à se faire réélire la remporter
l'investiture dans sa propre
circonscription de bendtner a du côté
des libéraux auraient fait élire sept
députés en 2018 ils sont toujours il
était toujours cette au moment de la
dissolution avec l'ajout d'un mandat si
mal et puis le départ de m cotto oui pas
là qu'on voit le premier ministre
sortant d'oxford qui lui aussi
s'installe confortablement pour la
soirée électorale avec son épouse carla
et je vois au moins deux ou trois de ses
films se font en k4 filles avec lui
alors un sourire qui affiche beaucoup de
confiance on verra bien ce que ça va
donner je vous rappelle que les premiers
résultats les bureaux de vote en tout
cas ferme dans moins de quatre minutes
maintenant on attend les résultats peu
de temps après velits péter deboer
montrer votre nom ou votre carte voici à
quoi avait l'air notre province en 2018
2022 c'est encore à tout blanc pour le
moment on attend les résultats dès 21h
on va commencer à voir le dépouillage
des votes et puis les couleurs vont
commencer à s'insérer tout au long de la
soirée ce sont les électeurs qui vont
colorer cette carte là c'est la beauté
de notre démocratie
natacha geneviève une campagne on le
disait avec avec matthieu simard qui a
pas nécessairement survie de grandes
passions chez l'électeur n'est ce pas
écoutez c'est probablement la campagne
la plus anémique qu'on a vu en ontario
depuis longtemps au début de la campagne
on se demandait qui du npd ou des
libéraux allaient gagner le vote
progressiste en s'approprier le vote de
gauche on se demandait si sa lettre les
libéraux dans la première semaine ils
ont eu une bonne semaine on l'entendait
dans le topo de catherine le transport
en commun à un dollar une promesse tape
à l'oeil qui a fait couler
d'encre mais ils ont eu l'air de perdre
leur momentum et les sondages au final
sont restés à peu près pareil du début à
la fin de sa lecture
du tout bougé c'est peut-être l'arrivée
du printemps c'est peut-être la fatigue
qu'ovide mais les ontariens étaient
visiblement pas au rendez vous là et les
conservateurs n'ont plus de quoi non
plus d'emplois de voulu garder les
choses très calme on l'a vu le message à
contrôler très contrôlé une différence
complète avec l'élection de 2018 ou là
on entendait beaucoup d'autres fois il y
avait des controverses y avait des
controverses ou sécher ses propres
députés cette fois ci le message a été
vraiment script et une ligne de conduite
très clair peu d'apparitions aussi on
allait dans des endroits stratégiques
et ça aussi ça la contribué à ce calme
là ce qui a fait que les partis
d'opposition ont pas trouvées prises
pour attaquer d'oxford il a été quasi
inattaquable le but c'était de ne pas
trop faire de vagues dans le bassin où
exactement le but c'était que monsieur
fouad ne fasse pas de gaffe quand il est
arrivé au pouvoir il a une proche
conseillère melissa lantsman qui est
aujourd'hui députée conservatrice au
fédéral qui disait que monsieur fortier
était comme un taureau dans un magasin
de porcelaine lorsqu'il ouvrait la
bouche a les cheveux se dresser sur la
nuque de stratèges parce qu'il était
vraiment imprévisible et là dans cette
campagne il a été extrêmement discipliné
ça nous a étonnés même donc je crois on
s'attendait à ce qu'il fasse des gaffes
mais non il s'en est tenu à ses
rassemblements il a presque pas parlé
aux médias ils ont rejoint les électeurs
autrement donc il ya eu beaucoup
d'appels automatisés
il ya une armée de bénévoles aux portes
de force et beaucoup adressé aux radios
privées il ya également laissé de se
vendre comme un politicien proche du
peuple un mot sur l'île
les chefs des partis d'opposition qui
joue dans certains cas leur avenir à la
morgate d'abord qu'est ce que ça lui
prend est ce qu elle peut rester en
poste après l'élection ça va être
difficile tout le monde s'entend pour
dire qu'elle n'a pas fait une bonne
campagne alors qu'elle aurait dû faire
une bonne campagne alors l'expérience
alors l'es5 petit du public on l'a senti
fatigué à peu près tout le long de la
campagne en plus j'ai eu plein de pépin
ils sont dehors de son contrôle mais
c'est comme quand ça va mal ça ça va ça
va donc je peux probablement que les
gens vont se dire ben elle a peut-être
offert tout ce qu'elle avait offert puis
on propos faire plus de gueule envers
les résultats le mais c'est fort
possible que c'est sa dernière quand il
s'était vite d'être du coeur d'attaché
écoutez il faut qu'il fasse renaître le
parti de ces semble sept députés en 2018
c'était catastrophique mais probablement
son premier défi ce soir 6 de se faire
élire dans sa propre circonscription le
vendre ou de bridge il l'a perdue par
8000 voix la dernière fois mike oddih
borloo son adversaire le progressiste
conservateur était et bien aimé dans la
circonscription c'était un ministre au
cabinet de d'oxford donc ça va être
difficile là pour monsieur
d'applications dit qu'on va surveiller
parmi cent vingt-quatre autres très
attentivement mes rêves 2 il sera 21h
dans moins de dix secondes l'heure des
résultats est arrivé toute l'équipe est
prête à vivre ce moment avec vous
[Musique]
il est maintenant 21h les bureaux de
scrutin sont maintenant fermés presque
partout en ontario jeudi presque partout
parce que le vote a été prolongé dans
une vingtaine de circonscriptions
pendant toutes les circonscriptions mais
dans certains bureaux de ses comptes et
leurs qui ont ouvert plus tard où il ya
eu certains problèmes informatiques on
parle de prolongation du vote de 10 15
20 minutes dans certains cas ça vaut
jusqu'à deux heures dans un cas en
particulier mais ça devrait pas trop
affecter les résultats qu'on vous
présentait ce soir vous allez voir
apparaître au bas de votre écran le
décompte des différents partis c'est à 0
pour le moment évidemment mais lorsque
livre premier vote vont entrer ça va
s'animer tout ça est ce classement là va
être mise à jour je vous rappel des
chiffres importants de la soirée 63,6 qu
un parti doit obtenir au moins 63 sièges
pour former un gouvernement majoritaire
d'attaché geneviève je reviens vers vous
on surveille quoi particulièrement
l'action se comprennent loupé au regard
de la carte de ce qu'il faut regarder ce
soir mais évidemment on va surveiller la
couronne de torrents toile ses loques se
jouent toutes les élections en ontario
qu'elle soit fédérales ou provinciales
ce soir il ya plusieurs luttes serrées
entre les libéraux et les progressistes
conservateurs qu'on surveille on sait
que les électeurs sont fluides dans
cette région lol il passe du bleu au
rouge la dernière fois donc fall est
allé chercher des circonscription
traditionnellement rouges est ce qu'il
peut les maintenir ce soir on va aussi
surveiller toronto même parce que
l'effort des luttes entre les libéraux
et le npd alors allez une petite allée
chercher beaucoup de sièges libéraux la
dernière fois l'on va vouloir voir s'ils
vont pouvoir les rattraper et on va
aussi surveiller d'autres régions je
pense le sud ouest par exemple hamilton
niagara un peu l'honneur voir si
d'autres fois il a effectivement fait
ses idées je t'en aller chercher à vivre
auprès des députés npd et les voici
21h01 les premiers résultats de cette
soirée électorale bienvenus oui voilà on
a un premier résultat dans richmond hill
qui avait été en fait un gain des
progressistes conservateurs en 2018 mais
leur candidate est en deuxième position
en ce moment avec à une boîte dépouillés
sur 69 donc ce sont encore des résultats
très froidement seule chose car même
c'est pas beaucoup
de bruit manager me ouest le député
sortant néo démocrate est en avance de
deux votes sur le libéral david ferrer
avec une boîte de dépouiller donc sur 89
encore une fois des résultats très très
fragmentaire pour l'astre 8 voix à peine
de compter dans ce bris a par là qu'on
voit le décompte du mpb ce serait quoi
on parlait de madame horvat une bonne
soirée pour le npd ce soir qui lui
permettrait peut-être de pouvoir
s'accrocher au pouvoir écoutez c'est
tout ou rien pour madame horvat ce soir
c'est la quatrième fois qu'elle tente de
devenir première ministre
treizième année à la tête du parti il
faut absolument qu'elle soit élue ce
soir qu'elle fasse mentir à peu près
tous les sondages d'ailleurs il faut que
maintiennent les 40 sièges qu'elle a
gagné la dernière fois plusieurs
desquels elle a volé des libéraux
s'étaient défiés libéraux il faut
qu'elles maintiennent le siège dans le
sud ouest de l'ontario qui sont dans la
ligne de mire de d'oxford là il faut que
les autres partis fassent mal alors
faudrait que les conservateurs soient
est minoritaire il faudrait que les
libéraux arrivent pas faire des gains
donc s'il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
en dehors de son contrôle c'est pour ça
un puck on n'a pas une ne connaît pas
optimiste quant à la mauvaise parce
qu'on dit malgré toute la bonne volonté
de la bonne performance ça sera pas
assez parce qu'on voit mal pour
l'instant ni respect des douaniers
devenir gouvernement puis même être dans
l'opposition officielle ils sont déjà ce
sera sans doute parce après quatre
élections des fois il ya un désir de
changement de la part même des militants
du parti madame horvat on lui pose la
question plus tôt cette semaine allez
vous rester dit j'attends le verdict des
ontariens pour décider on verra ce qu'il
aura à dire ce soir on va retrouver
myriam et d'ailleurs qui regarde cette
soirée électorale compagnie d'une d'une
famille du de la grande région de
kitchener c'est ça
non on est à environ 1h30 de toronto
c'est pas loin de quechua mathieu on
avec la famille base une famille canado
syrienne ici les allégeances politiques
sont dix cantons un petit peu libérale
un petit peu de balles on essaie avec
tammy baj vous vous penchez pour les
verts dites moi qu'est ce que vous allez
surveiller ce soir je vais surveiller
les cerises conscription dans le grand
toronto car je veux voir ce qui se passe
avec les libéraux car ils ont assurément
comme sept sièges la dernière fois je
veux voir s'ils vont remporter d'autres
sièges et voir aussi cette contribution
à surveiller l écocentre et les néo
démocrates et les progressistes
conservateurs ou les présentateurs et
les libéraux et voir qui va l'emporter
là-bas donc ici à ward luz et une
circonscription néo démocrates
actuellement détenu par une députée néo
démocrate est ce que vous espérez un
changement de parti bien sûr j'aimerais
que les verts l'emportent
circonscription mais je pense que les
des homes néo démocrates vont la garder
avec un franck fife et puis je suis
quand même ok avec ce résultat je ne
suis pas vraiment l'aider au démocrate
je préfère les verts cette fois ci mais
je serais quand même content avec le
résultat et sami qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de la campagne électorale en
ontario cette année homme je pense que
les verts ils ont une très très bonne
campagne j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que mike
lenhoff avec sa performance au débat
j'aime comment il l'a pas été il était
un esprit très collaboratif très
collaborateurs il n'est pas très négatif
et c'est une des raisons projets
distincts votés vers cette fois ci aussi
aussi pour et ceci j'ai trouvé des néo
démocrates devancent leurs stratégies de
l'utiliser les résultats de 2018 pour
payant votre tv comment port et puis
dans les pionts 2018 ou en 2022 et on
est à voir le loup comme je le disais
avec la famille bas âge on a aussi l'ami
de samy qui est ici qui s'est joint à la
fête à la soirée électorale vous qu'est
ce que vous allez surveiller ce soir moi
je surveille habituellement les
les les parties de la province ou un
parti particulier se trouve à une plus
forte alors pour le npd par exemple ça
serait la région d'armentières la région
de sudbury j'assure vais aussi les
résultats où il ya une grande population
francophone alors il ya de la région
d'ottawa la question de sudbury la
région
près de windsor un petit peu
on va continuer de suivre la soirée
électorale en direct d'un salon avec
nous pour vous à bientôt à bientôt
certainement myriam qu'on va retrouver
un toro de la soirée hâte de voir ce que
ces gens la base des résultats des
résultats d'ailleurs dans la région
d'ottawa dans le comté de nepean donc
lisa macleod la ministre sortante des
industries du patrimoine du sport du
tourisme et de la culture qui a une
légère avance pour l'instant sur son
rival libéral dans ottawa-centre le
député sortant néo-démocrate a aussi une
légère avance sur sa rivale libérale
avec une boîte de dépouiller sur 120 est
dans l'un des centres narnia le candidat
progressiste conservateur qu'il ya une
avance d'un seul vote sur sa plus proche
rivale la libérale kate g kg si vous si
le nom vous dit quelque chose c'est que
elle a participé à la course à la
chefferie en fait du parti libéral
contre stephen del duca justement et
voici là où on en est en ce moment les
tout premiers résultats très très
fragmentaire ça entre par man au
compte-gouttes je voudrais pour le
moment on a trois candidats en tête pour
le npd 2 pour le parti conservateur pour
le moment on parle de quelques poignées
de vote pour l'instant on a parlé de ce
qui serait une bonne soirée pour pour le
npd quelles sont les attentes pour le
premier ministre sortant d'oxford elle
est où la barre qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent à obtenir aujourd'hui écoutez
d'abord fo qui maintient ses acquis dans
le grand toronto puis geneviève en
parlais tantôt je pense que le faire des
gains dans le sud ouest de l'ontario
dans la région de windsor secteur
automobile à l'un d'eux mêmes à niagara
ça serait une belle victoire pour
monsieur faute à ce casting justement
que sa stratégie d'aller chercher les
travailleurs c'est une nouvel électorat
pour les progressistes-conservateurs en
refonctionner est le premier résultat
d'un golf pour un autre chef mike
schreiner regardez déjà la vence
303 voix d'avancé avec une seule boîte
de scrutin de dépouiller mais ce sera un
honneur qui devrait en principe remporté
assez facilement sa circonscription de
golf une seule boîte de scrutin mais
déjà une large avance pour le chef des
verts ce sera un lieu je souhaiterais
peut-être avoir des amis avec lui à
queen's park il est tout seul depuis
quatre ans il est tout seul ça pas été
facile d'ailleurs si on regarde où il
s'est déplacé durant toute la campagne
essentiellement fait campagne dans guen
qui était son propre compte et on l'a
pas vu à l'échelle de la province où ça
monte un peu la difficulté du parti vert
en ontario puis un peu au canada je
voudrais le momentum qu'on attendait
chez les verts et pas vraiment arriver
c'est pas encore l'heure pour le parti
vert de se faire élire alors on rit on y
voit la pièce on a un côté on veut se
garder on veut aller cherche un deuxième
puits aujourd'hui on parle de peut-être
deux qu'on dit mais pas vraiment plus et
là ça commence à s'animer au bas de
notre écran des premiers résultats dans
vos news brut je vous disais qu'on
surveille ça de très très près parce que
c'est la circonscription de steve del
duca chef du parti libéral qui est pour
le moment deux dixièmes une seule pas de
scruter de dépouiller les une avance de
138 voix pour michael thibault l'eau qui
a été ministre qui a occupé divers
postes depuis quatre ans dans le
gouvernement de d'oxford monsieur del
duca qui a déjà représenté la région à
queen's park qui était ministre sous
l'ancien gouvernement de kathleen wynne
mais qu'il a espère obtenir un siège ce
soit à queen's park donc pour le moment
monsieur del duca et à deuxième voyez là
on est à 16 pour les consommateurs 4
pour le npd 2 chez les libéraux et il y
à un pur pour le parti vert
revenons
revenons au chef monsieur del duca et
sept députés la dernière fois santos
politique se sera pas nécessairement
difficile de faire mieux mais on veut
quoi comme objectif on veut la deuxième
place c'est clair mais lol contrairement
au npd ou c'est pas tout entre leurs
mains les libéraux c'est entre leurs
mains ils peuvent gagner ils peuvent
dépasser le npd et ça prend aussi la
victoire de monsieur del duca enfin plus
pour son avenir personnel mais on veut
très certainement la deuxième place si
on le pommeau et on est prêt peut-être
on verra comment les militants reçoivent
ce message met clairement oui on va
deuxième on va aller on va les retrouver
mathieu simard qui est au quartier
général des conservateurs qui ont
maintenant 21 candidats en avance
matthieu simard quelle est l'ambiance
chez vous est ce que c'est le genre de
début de soirée à que les conservateurs
espéraient
bien écouter on va vous montrer il ya
beaucoup d'ambiance si au fur et à
mesure que le compteur augmente en
faveur des progressistes-conservateurs
ya la foule qui ici donc voyez là on
voit même jeu parce qu'on peut montrer
les images doc rôle qui suit les
résultats à quelques pas d'ici dans une
chambre d'hôtel en compagnie de sa
famille monsieur poulpe qui ensuite la
vasque et d'un pays ici au centre de
conférences de toronto donc je voudrais
que c'est le premier roman là où les
livres partisans progressistes
conservateurs
on sent leur frénésie parce que les
résultats favorables rentrer à leur
faveur comme je suis un petit peu plus
tôt c'est le résultat qu'on attend ici
chez les progressistes conservateurs on
veut une victoire et même on veut
défaire le chef libéral stephen odell du
code en vente goodrich pour l'instant
les résultats semblent en faveur du
candidat progressiste conservateur
monsieur thibault l'eau donc ça anime la
foule derrière moi
merci matthieu simard 24 députés aux
candidats d' avance pour les
conservateurs pour le moment on est à 10
chez le npd camille guy roy on parle de
la bataille pour la deuxième place
qu'elle est très importante ce soit vous
êtes avec une organisatrice du parti oui
absolument mélanie richer qui a fait
partie de cette équipe de campagne et
qui d'habitude travail pour le npd
fédéral mais qui est venu donner un coup
de pouce alors quel bilan est ce que
vous tirez de cette campagne on y suit
pas faire notre campagne on ne fume
aident les histoires des gens à chaque
jour de nouvelles âmes sais quelque
chose n'est supérieure que l ai pu aller
chercher les histoires des gens allaient
parler du fait que les gens ont besoin
des soins dentaires qui ont besoin des
soins de santé mentale qui vraiment
élever leurs problèmes dans une scène
provinciale pour que les gens la maison
voici l'histoire lens on est vraiment
fier de
ça on est vraiment fiers du fait que
maintenant ça n'est pas n'importe quoi
les résultats ce soir que vraiment le
npd est une force en ontario c'est un
parti qui peut former le gouvernement
qui est on va voir les résultats ce soir
mais on est fiers la campagne est ce que
la chef joue son avenir ce soir si elle
n'est pas élue et même si elle n'est pas
la chef de l'opposition officielle on
veut voir qu'est ce qui se passe ce soir
comme je dis on espère faire injure je
pense que hadja aussi fier la campagne
on va voir qu'est ce qui se passe sur
les résultats mais pour l'instant
en battant les résultats parfaits me
lanier riche et on va vous laisser
retourner dans la salle donc une demande
de la campagne d'andré horvath merci cas
mais il ya des résultats maintenant dans
52 des 124 circonscriptions de l'ontario
ça commence à se préciser et voici la
première élue de la soirée voilà donc
dans new york simcoe carolyn maloney qui
arrive à se faire réélire donc aller
devant largement devant déjà son plus
proche rival libéral la dernière fois
aussi ça avait été aussi facile pour
elle elle avait gagné 1 par plus de
quinze mille voix elle donc obtient son
deuxième mandat donc sur une brousse la
ministre sortant de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et des affaires rurales
lice à thompson arrive aussi à se faire
réélire fuir en brousse qui est un
château fort et progressiste
conservateur elle brigue son 4e mandat
elle l'obtient l'islam selon le rappel
elle a occupé plusieurs postes au sein
du cabinet du gouvernement faute d'offre
intelligence sylvia jones la solliciteur
général sortant qui est aussi réélue
selon les projections de radio canada
elle avait obtenu la dernière fois aussi
une large avance sur ses rivaux alors
c'est un cinquième mandat qu'elle
obtient à queen's park
dans le ring flou les piscines pembrooke
john yakabuski qui arrive aussi à se
faire réélire il obtient un sixième
mandat pour lui aussi la dernière fois
ça avait été très très facile alors donc
il est on donne pour l'instant il est en
avance par rapport à ces à son rival
nécessairement surprise à ce coin l'est
de l'ontario qui a l'habitude de voter
conservateur voici le classement pour le
moment cinq élus 34 candidats en tête
total de 39 pour les
progressistes-conservateurs treize
candidats en tête chez npd on est à 7
chez les libéraux or pour le parti vert
pour le moment et en termes de suffrages
exprimés bon c'est tôt dans la soirée ça
pourrait bouger un peu mais 40% des voix
chez les conservateurs c'est à peu près
du copier coller de ce qu'ils avaient
obtenu en 2010 8 24 pour s'acheter des
libéraux qui pour l'instant font mieux
qu'en 2018 23 pour sachet de npd et 7
pour ça pour le parti vert d'attaché à
geneviève natacha d'abord vos premières
impressions sur ce début de soirée
qu'est ce qu'on lit là dedans écoutez
ces préliminaires là mais ça semble bien
se dessiner pour d'autres fois la date
je regarde justement les chiffres encore
une fois pris les mineurs mais dans le
grand toronto à date les
progressistes-conservateurs conserve à
peu près tout adapte ce qui est sorti et
il semble être en avance dans brahms et
non ça c'est une région qu'ils avaient
vraiment à l'oeil ils ont promis de
construire une autoroute dans la
couronne ouest de toronto et c'était
précisément pour aller capturer cet
électorat là le tout porté dès le
printemps je suis alors c'est ce qu'ils
avaient gagné 7 40,6 en 2018 là on est
là et c'est préliminaire va voir la
suite mais intéressant parti vert qui
fait plus aussi et voilà le parti vert
et qui fait plus c'est grâce à grâce à
cet homme là le chef mike schreiner
kyrie lui d'un golf on parlait de la
forte avance même avec très peu de
boîtes de scrutin mais ce choix une
heure qui a obtenu à peu près plus de
40% des voix 2018 puis qu'il a donc
obtient à nouveau gagne à nouveau son
siège à tunis pas que la grande question
qu'ont les verts ce soir est ce que
monsieur choix et ne va réussir à avoir
de la compagnie à avoir un autre une
autre députée avec lui aqmi bancaire
n'est pas que cette année par là qu'on
voit des images en direct du quartier
général du parti vert vont tous les
chiffres parce que le portrait vous
précisez vont s'adresser à la foule
qu'on attend mais ce choix nous la
gohelle faire un petit peu plus tard ce
soit ses passes sont pas allés voir
philippe avec sa carte qui était toute
blanche tout à l'heure faites nous un
petit survol de l'ontario ça ressemble à
quoi oui absolument mais je compare
d'abbas ce que tu es la carte en 2018
lors on regarde la circonscription de
tain de b supérieur nar qui pourrait
passer aux mains des néo démocrates dans
le nord de l'ontario pour le reste quand
même c'est quand même on parle d'un
copier coller le pour le reste la
province allons dans l'est ontarien où
le seul changement qu'on voit pour
l'instant si on regarde entre 2018 et
maintenant les résultats qui rentre de
2022 bon ça change en temps réel mais on
surveille attentivement la
circonscription de glengarry prescott
grâce aux amendes à simard qui avait
longtemps parlé tantôt qui a changé plan
avec les passes et des progressistes
conservateurs aux libéraux pour
l'instant c'est son adversaire
comme progressiste conservateur qui mène
dans cette course la messe est en
croissance cette circonscription le
change un peu de couleurs un peu comme
dans la belle au bois dormant consent à
la couleur de la robe ça change de
seconde en seconde allant voir dans la
couronne de toronto maintenant
whisky stéphane sarrazin qui se
présentent quant à moi d'assumer ce
samedi inquiète un maire dans l'est
ontarien et régions ont conservé de très
très près ses sorties voici le grand
toronto donc 2018 quand même une rafle
et un raz-de-marée progressiste
conservateur qu'il avait permis aux uns
ou aux troupes de doc forte de remporter
une majorité là on voit quand même qu'on
conserve plusieurs de ces
circonscriptions là on voit dans votre
circonscription
convoité par le chef libéral et qu'il
est acculé derrière son adversaire
progressistes-conservateurs par 815 voix
si on se concentre maintenant dans la
rédac dans toronto un monde voit
quelques changements que ça fait un pur
ça fait un peu mal aux yeux le mais
quelques changements du côté avoue wrap
vous rappeler en 2008 les néo-démocrates
avaient remporté tout ses
circonscriptions là et là on voit qu'il
a quand même possiblement des gains
libéraux qui se dessine notamment dans
toronto saint paul où la néo-démocrate
jorane jour tire un peu de la patte pour
l'instant ici dans beach the hills turc
la une l'ex conseillère municipale de
toronto meriem crête mec mal acquis qui
semble en très bonne posture dans partie
cette circonscription la donc céder oui
oui des résultats quand même très
préliminaire pour voilà faut le dire des
démarches davance pas nécessairement
énorme mais avec des résultats
maintenant dans plus de 90 124
circonscriptions c'est quand même un bon
début de soirée on peut dire pour les
conservateurs on va se rendre dans le
sud de la province elvis nous même si
vous êtes dans la circonscription des
sexes qu'est-ce que ça ressemble à bas
écoutez il ya déjà un certain nombre de
personnes ici à une bonne cinquantaine
de personnes je dirais qu'ils sont
arrivés qui ont applaudi le candidat
l'arrêté 1h18 radio canada prévoit si la
tendance du vote se maintient que le
prochain gouvernement notariaux sera
formée par le parti progressiste
conservateur et que ce sera un
gouvernement majoritaire
je répète radio canada prévoit si la
tendance au meetic le prochain
gouvernement dont dario sera formée par
les progressistes conservateurs et que
ce sera un gouvernement majoritaire
on va voir des images en direct de la
permanence des conservateurs à etobicoke
la foule qui s'animent les partisans de
plus en plus nombreux c'est donc pari
réussi pour le premier ministre sortant
dr qui obtient non seulement un deuxième
mandat à la tête de la province est
seulement de la est majoritaire ça veut
dire les coudées franches pour faire
adopter son programme adopté son budget
et ses rangs de l'opposition qui avait
dit on ne supporterait pas le
gouvernement minoritaire de john ford eh
bien on n'aura pas à se pencher sur ce
scénario la voix si nous on en est en ce
moment on y à 13 élus 44 candidats en
taille totale de cette recette pour les
conservateurs n'a pas encore atteint le
chiffre magique de 63 vous avez raison
sauf qu'ils restent des résultats à
venir dans plus d'une trentaine de
circonscriptions et radio canada
projette avec ses résultats à venir que
la barre 63 soit aisément dépasser pour
les conservateurs on est à 24 pour le
npd 6 à peine pour les libéraux et un
élu pour le parti vert retournant chez
les conservateurs avant de voir les
résultats du doigt de 40% un
conservateur 24/24 égalité statistique
pour le npd et les libéraux et 7 pour
cent du vote recueilli pour le parti
vert pour le moment matthieu simard donc
chez les gays
d'abord premiers résultats pour d'oxford
dans et toby couleurs monsieur faure qui
va certainement remporté également sa
propre circonscription trois boîtes de
scrutin dépouillées sur 38 une avance de
349 voix mais se fonde sur la plus
proche candidate qui du parti guibert
alors est-ce qu'on parlait vont
maintenant chez les conservateurs match
usma parlez-nous de lanvian chez vous
mais moi que c'est confirmé la
réélection de monsieur x
on sent beaucoup la frénésie et je vous
dirai ma tuque ce post est pas une
surprise pour personne c'est vraiment le
résultat qu'on attendait ici ce soir
l'équipe d'oxford est très très
confiante de décrocher un deuxième
mandat mais on sentait tout de même
qu'avec avait encore cette pression est
là on a senti lorsqu'on a lens on a
confirmé que ce sera un gouvernement
majoritaire ont ressenti le soulagement
de la part des partisans qui sont réunis
ici on vient vraiment envie un poids de
sur leurs épaules donc beaucoup de joie
beaucoup prennent ainsi nos nerfs elle a
ce talent elle est devenue très bruyante
au moment d'annoncer que les
progressistes conservateurs allaient
former le gouvernement est un
gouvernement majoritaire et donc puisque
les résultats préliminaires nous disent
ici c'est que les ontariens veulent
faire confiance à d'oxford et à son
équipe pour un deuxième mandat à saboter
aussi que la stratégie de réélection de
d'oxford a fonctionné on a misé on a
bien miser sur cette stratégie qui est
bon qu'ils mettaient de l'avant pays des
investissements en infrastructures des
grands chantiers un peu partout en
ontario et est clairement à la foule se
réjouit des résultats ici ce soir je
vous rappelle qu'on est dans la
circonscription de d'oxford est au big
honneur qu'on appelle aussi la ford
machine au centre de conférences de
toronto il n'hésite pas qu'est ce qu'on
vous dit mathieu sur l'heure
approximative aux autres quand est ce
que monsieur fall devrait arriver faire
son discours on l'a vu tout à l'heure
qui regardaient les résultats très
attentivement avec avec sa famille
donc monsieur faure qui dans une chambre
d'hôtel à proximité un compagnie des
membres de sa famille de ses trois
filles de sa femme on nous dit qu'ils
devraient venir ici au centre de
conférence pour commencer son discours
vers 10h un il est tout près à proximité
et donc aux dernières nouvelles 10
heures c'est l'heure qu'on nous avait
donné pour le discours de victoire de
monsieur foued qui va venir ici célébrer
avec type des partisans son deuxième
mandant à queen's park de disco qu'on va
vous présenter évidemment en direct
merci beaucoup monsieur
natacha geneviève donc après tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis 2 2 puis 4 1 en fait
depuis deux ans et la pandémie depuis
quatre ans comme explique monsieur x de
réussi à obtenir un gouvernement
majoritaire un autre gouvernement alors
que peu de temps après son élection il
sentait qu'il disait il ils survivront
même pas jusqu'à la fin de son mandat
tout un tour de force quand même assez
1,95 transformé pour plusieurs z'ont
notamment par la pandémie mais pas juste
la pandémie avant la pandémie il y avait
déjà réalisé qu'ils devaient être moins
polarisant moins combatif et il s'est
révélé durant la pandémie comme étant le
premier ministre de tous les ontariens
est ce qu'on n'avait pas vraiment vu en
début de mandat ans est conseiller
municipal parler davantage aux gens de
toronto et donc il le prix sont serrés
les épaules la responsabilité de la
province et présenté une vision qui est
essentiellement une vision économique
assez
positive je voudrais même d'espoir et ça
a été ça a été rentable pour me surprend
parce qu'en 2018 c'était une élection de
changement les ontariens voulait se
débarrasser de kaffrine wind et ce soir
c'est du moins une élection de statu quo
on va voir si c'est un couronnement on
va voir s'il va obtenir plus de sièges
les ontariens qui ont cette fois je
crois voté pour d'oxford et non en dépit
de notre faute donc tout ce qu'il avait
à faire on en parlait c'était de ne pas
faire de vagues de suivre son chemin des
disciplines et est clairement que ça a
payé aussi il ya quand même 60 % des
ontariens qui semble pas avoir voté pour
d'autres fois que ce soit en live vous
parliez de l'égalité statistiques
indienne [ __ ] et des libéraux cette
division du vote progressiste ça permet
aux progressistes-conservateurs devenir
s'insérer entre les deux dans plusieurs
circonscriptions lui-même et un résultat
qui est étonnant c'est le voit sans
tâche des autres partis ni nouveau parti
qui ont été créés tout à fait le parti
bleu partie notariaux maintenant ils
sont à devrait à cinq pour cent du vote
pas suffisant pour nuire à notre faute
c'est quand même assez intéressant
exactement ça veut dire quoi
concrètement pour les ontariens et la
réélection de doc folle qu'est ce qui va
ce qui va changer de se poursuivre dans
leur vie ont du budget d'environ n'ai eu
un budget c'est sûr que le budget adopté
tel quel et les promesses par exemple
d'enlever les frais d'immatriculation
les rabais sur l'essence beaucoup de
constructions ça doit trancher sur la
taxe oui pour un limites et d'ailleurs
est ce qu'on sait pas mais qui va
peut-être aussi se dessiner monsieur
foued beaucoup collaboré avec justin
trudeau alors c'est possible qu'il y ait
d'autres collaborations pour d'autres
graves et après on verra cette fameuse
autoroute d'achat d'autant de temps
parler l'autoroute 413 pour ceux qui
connaissent pas trop la région toronto
le mais une autoroute qui doit ceinture
et le nord ouest de toronto qui
coûterait quoi 10 milliards de dollars
ça ce sont des situations oui parce que
l'enfant cette autoroute là le
gouvernement libéral précédent de casse
mingas in win a considéré la construit
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya des
problèmes de congestion dans cette
section la du grand toronto donc ils ont
fait des études indépendantes et se sont
rendus compte que l'autoroute ne
sauverait que 30 secondes aux
automobilistes à leur partenaire
étonnant ils sont pas aller dans cette
direction là et quand monsieur fall est
arrivé au pouvoir je dirais plutôt ça
fait ils n'ont pas seulement depuis un
an c'est très intéressant en fait lui a
fait sa propre étude n'ont pas vu les on
n'a pas vu les chiffres à mes yeux
disent que ça va sauver 30 minutes aux
automobilistes et ils promettent de
construire cette eau et les autres
partis d'opposition avaient dit si on
est élu on avoir annulé ce projet
d'autoroute 413 monsieur fois que je
vais la construire on peut imaginer
qu'avec un mandat majoritaire il pourra
le faire philippe votre carte scolaire
de plus en plus un instant par la
compagnie de montfort voici des
nouvelles toutes fraîches de sa
circonscription d'etobicoke d'oxford
réélu non seulement comme premier
ministre mais comme député dé tobiko
nord un autre mandat donc pour monsieur
ford a dans sa circonscription une bonne
marge d'avancé pour pour lui et il va
compter sur l'appui de plusieurs membres
de son cabinet qui sont également réélu
bien voilà dans pickering explique
julien apprend donc le ministre sortant
des finances peer bethlenfalvy est réélu
selon les projections de radio-canada
dans les annexes
steve clarke y ministre sortant des
affaires municipales et du logement
également réélu
dans les piscines dans le nord de
l'ontario vic fedeli qui ministre
sortant de développement économique de
la création d'emplois et du commun c'est
également réélu c'est une personnalité
assez connu dans la région il a été
maire de north bay bien avant donc de
aller en provence nahla sur la scène
provinciale et il a donc justement une
nette avance sur sa concurrente aux
néo-démocrates kanata 40 m dans l'est
ontarien mary lee fulton qui ministre
sortante des services à l'enfance et les
services sociaux et communautaires qui
est également réélu on la connaît
peut-être plus pour le rôle qu'elle
avait occupé auparavant deux ministres
des soins de longue durée ça n'a pas
toujours été facile évidemment dans ce
portefeuille là on le sait il ya eu
beaucoup de critiques sur la gestion de
ce dossier là en pandémie
dans le même temps mme kent middlesex
dans le sud ouest ontarien a menti mais
knapen qui est un ministre sortant du
travail de la formation et du
développement qui est également un réélu
il obtient son quatrième mandat à
queen's park
et voilà réélection également pour une
autre chef andriat horvat chef du npd on
peut confirmer qu'elle va remporter sa
circonscription d'hamilton centre
qu'elle représente depuis je crois 2004
en tout cas ça fait longtemps qu'elle
est la députée d'aménité une centre elle
est en est à sa quatrième élection à
titre de chef déjà une très bonne avance
pour pour madame horvat qui compte pour
l'instant moins de députés avec elle à
queen's park on n'a pas des résultats
dans la totalité des 124
circonscriptions mais rappelez vous en
2018 le npd avait obtenu 40 sièges on
est à 25 pour le moment alors ce n'est
certainement pas le genre de soirées
auxquelles pouvaient aspirer les
néo-démocrates et et madame horvath
philippe montrez nous votre votre carte
qui sera et vous voyez au bas de l'écran
dans les dents le bilan des partis il ya
un 1 devant le siège à dépendant pour
l'instant c'est assez rare dans une
soirée électorale de voir du gris
apparaître sur la carte donc allons voir
dans la région justement d'année le
thème niagara c'est cette
circonscription dans le domaine de
norfolk norfolk où en ce moment c'est un
candidat indépendant bobby abreu dit
qu'ils mènent sur le progressiste
conservateur can do it
hors domaine dans le foie qui est une
transcription en 2018 qui était
progressiste conservatrice donc ce sera
intéressant de voir ya encore seulement
13 à boîtes de scrutin et ont été
dépouillés pour le moment mais ce sera
intéressant de voir au courant de la
soirée 6 700 contribution là va
finalement avoir un député indépendant
oui parce que bon c'est non on n'avait
pas vu souvenirs personnes progression
vegas ce coin de l'ontario avec beaucoup
d'attention on va aller faire un petit
tour chez les libéraux je parlais du
chiffre 63 important à retenir le
chiffre 12 aussi est important pour les
libéraux parce que c'est ce que ça prend
pour regagner le statut de parti
officiel à l'assemblée législative
catherine pour l'instant on est à 9 chez
les libéraux ça ne doit pas être la très
grande fête chez vous
on est loin de la célébration ainsi
polir personnes a été vraiment surpris
lors de l'annoncé de la victoire
annoncée donc des conservateurs mais ce
que les gens observent avec attention
vous l'avez dit si ce nombre de députés
qu'obtiendront les libéraux que vont
derrière moi il ya quand même beaucoup
de gens qui sont là qui se sont
présentés pour ces célébrations jadis
célébration en soulignant l' en
soulignant l'aspect de ce mot fait ce
que bon il faut savoir ces gens là ont
travaillé pendant les dernières semaines
le dernier mois d'art achetées pour
tenter de mener leurs factures oui à une
victoire mais sinon au moins à des gains
à la récupération de leur statut comme
partie officielle et peut-être à
l'obtention du statut d'opposition
officielle mais tout ça ça semble de
plus en plus hors de portée au fur et à
mesure qu entre les résultats est ce qui
rend encore sa plus difficile c'est
qu'en ce moment dans la ses
constructions ici devant notre budget
bien le candidat qui le chef libéral
estime d'elles du camp alors on rappelle
encore une fois eh bien ils tirent de
l'arrière derrière le conservateur mike
ribeiro évidemment il ya seulement un
quart environ la des bureaux de scrutin
qui ont été aidées dont les résultats
sont connus pour l'instant mais il
connaît quand même un recul important
donc tout ce qui rend les célébrations
un peu plus difficile du côté des
quartiers généraux libéraux
les élections tout à l'heure qu'est ce
qu'on vous dit dans le camp libéral
quand est ce qu'on la tasse et quels
sont ses projets de discours tout à
l'heure
on sait qu'ils se trouvent à l'arrière
ici qu'ils écoutent les résultats dans
une salle juste à proximité de la salle
où a lieu la rencontre ce qu'on nous a
dit c'est qu'il y aurait bel et bien un
discours on espérait le faire après
celui de madame horvat renoncer à des
conversations entre les pierres en
partie à ce sujet donc potentiellement
au cours de la prochaine heure
évidemment toutefois on nous a dit que
c'était loin d'être certain dieu qu'il
s'adresserait aux médias donc il
répondrait à des questions tu donnerais
des entrevues fita c'est particulier on
nous dit que c'est pas un passé mais que
pour l'instant ce n'est pas ce qu'ils
planifient il veut plutôt consacrer sa
soirée à remercier les gens qui ont
travaillé dans le cadre de sa campagne
et a passé du temps également avec ses
proches sa famille merci catherine les
résultats de ce sont en tout cas vont
forcer une réflexion c'est certain chez
eux plusieurs parties des nouvelles de
dédicaces des libéraux riz élus world
avant ce but ottawa sud qui reste rouge
donc john fraser qui est réélu dans
cette circonscription john fraser qui on
sait avait assuré un rêve était chef
intérimaire du parti pendant qu'on se
chercher un nouveau chef après la
démission de kathleen wynne d'en-haut
relayant stephen blais qui lui aussi est
réélu c'est vraiment un bastion libéral
donc il obtient un deuxième mandat c'est
qu'il avait d'abord été élu à queen's
park en fait après le départ de marie
france la note
vous n'êtes pas une surprise pour ceux
crois hélas de la région d'ottawa qui
vote libéral habituellement continue
tombé respring ward aux roms et dont il
ya le candidat libéral qui est en avance
avec 21 une boîte dépouillés sur 67
c'est une circonscription de la
circonscription en fait du procureur
général sortant doc d'eni on verra
évidemment comment cette course-là va se
poursuivre dans le kingston et les îles
une avance encore une fois des libéraux
ted sous le candidat libéral qui a une
avance pour l'instant de 2300 voix
peaches east york à toronto meriem a
great mn qui a une avance de 399 fois
sur sa rivale qui est du puits
voilà pour les le tour des
circonscriptions libérales et voici des
nouvelles de la séquence qu'il son décès
son nid dans le sud de l'ontario
remportées par les conservateurs c'était
une circonscription néo démocrate
anthony léhady donc il remporte la
victoire selon les projections de radio
canada vous retrouvez elvis lorenzi et
qui sur place vous êtes justement élevé
je crois dans le cas conservateur
exactement et dans le quartier général
du parti pour us is to conservateur ici
ou ya quelques instants à peine c'était
vraiment gros soupir de soulagement
beaucoup d'applaudissements des gens qui
sont très enthousiastes parce qu'ils ont
appris que leurs candidats viennent tout
juste d'être élu il faut dire que c'est
quand même une sacrée performance parce
que comme vous le disiez tantôt c'était
un secteur qui a longtemps été npd et
donc c'est un gros changement et je
voudrais vous signaler aussi qu'il ya
une forme de tremblement de terre qui
vient de se produire pas très loin de
chez nous un tout petit peu au nord là
où on sortait comme si on envisageait
que ce serait le npd qui sortirait
vainqueur mais il s'avère que c'est un
parti pour aussi un candidat du parti
progressiste conservateur andrew d'un
wiki a été élu dans cette
circonscription la alors que justement
windsor ouest et wind chanté comme s'ils
ont traditionnellement a été décidée
construction qui
[Applaudissements]
l'encadrement de gros changements qui y
sont entrés les produits en seulement 6
e dont les chimistes
ont ils dit dans la circonscription des
sexes donc je dirais natacha pilier
conservateur réussissent à faire des
gains dans des bastions néo démocrates
comme comme le sud ouest la région
d'hamilton aussi c'est quand même
quelque chose et me ce fonds il a
travaillé fort oui et on travaille très
très fort la région alsace est une des
régions qui étaient les plus visités par
monsieur ford il l'a fait le pari que
oui les secteurs manufacturiers des
électeurs allaient voter pour lui avec
son programme de construction
d'infrastructures et on voit les
résultats ça a été payant pour
l'informer de la campagne avec ces
annonces avec justin trudeau à
répétition des usines de voitures et
tout le temps alors qu'il avait très mal
commencé au l'industrie automobile avait
eu beaucoup de coups durs durant les
deux premières années du mandat
la pandémie auprès des les bonnes
nouvelles sont arrivées que dernièrement
mais c'étaient des très bonnes nouvelles
l'industrie des batteries électriques
les voitures électriques tout son
honneur comme un vent d'optimisme ce
sport dans la région pour relancer un
secteur qui est quand même très
important première usine de batteries
électriques au canada là quand même
c'est pas rien on avait l'impression
d'ailleurs que justin trudeau faisait
campagne pour d'oxford en avant que la
campagne électorale soit lancée il y
avait ces annonces pas seulement à
windsor brampton également c'est que
c'est probablement la circonscription
que les progressistes conservateurs
voulaient le plus ravir à andre en vente
when there they come c'est là ça ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait sourciller
les stratèges d'oxford me disais que ces
gangs cette circonscription la la ça
veut dire qu'ils sont en très bonne
posture pour une majorité écrasante ou
du moins pour des gains sérieusement
intéressant il pensait même pas
eux-mêmes gagner cette circonscription
l'homme et la 76 et avec encore des
résultats à venir dans quelques
circonscriptions c'est exactement ce que
ce que monsieur ford avait obtenu il ya
quatre ans donc on peut être
possiblement augmenter ce chiffre l'on
parlait de justin trudeau les relations
fédérales-provinciales entre l'ontario
et et monsieur trudeau
il ya quatre ans c'était pas les
meilleurs amis du monde et là
soudainement tout va bien est ce que ça
vaut se poursuivre oui oui ça va se
poursuivre parce que monsieur x de
compris durant son mandat et il a
compris avant la pandémie que quand ça
va bien pour le canada ça va bien pour
l'ontario qui a plus de bénéfices à
collaborer avec le gouvernement fédéral
que de se battre contre le gouvernement
fédéral et ce monsieur ford avec la
pandémie il a complètement assimilé ces
venues renforcer ce message là et la
collaboration va sans doute se
poursuivre pensez aux garderies par
exemple ces fameuses garderie oui il ya
eu des tensions oui ça peut été signés
rapidement mais quand même ça a été fait
et s'étale avantages des deux aidés du
général il me faut comprendre aussi que
monsieur trudeau et monsieur ford là ils
partagent une base d'électeurs dans le
grand toronto ceux qui ont voté pour
d'oxford ce soir et y en a plusieurs
dans ce groupe là qui ont voté pour
monsieur trudeau à la dernière élection
et alexis l'élection avant ça et à
l'élection avant ciel donc reçu trudeau
avait pas intérêt à par exemple aller
aider monsieur del duca faire campagne
avec lui de toute manière les premiers
ministres du canada font pas campagne
avec leurs homologues et je sais que il
y en a dans le camp libéral
provincial qui ont été froissé le par
ces annonces avec d'autres vols avant la
campagne et l'absence d'appui il y avait
tellement une bonne relation kathleen
wynne puis justin trudeau jaseurs
poitiers nous aider à décider quand
presse monsieur trudeau prenait puis
mettez en place comme bonifier les
pensions on n'a pas du tout senti centre
monsieur des deux doit y avoir alors
qu'elle reste du corps veut changer les
pensions voulait sans doute forcé le
gouvernement fédéral à faire la même
chose puis on a jamais vu dialogue entre
les deux est là pour le moment 76
toujours candidat 77 voilà en avance
pour les conservateurs je vous entends
tu sur la visite et durant la pandémie
bon on est des nouvelles d'abord de
l'est de l'ontario une des courses qu'on
surveille de très près et qu'on suit
avec intérêt pour voir si amanda simard
la libérale mais qui avait d'abord été
élu comme progressiste conservatrice va
pas revenir donc à remporter un deuxième
mandat si maintenant elle se présente
avec les libéraux on sait qu'elle avait
quitté les progressistes-conservateurs
après les coupes en francophonie de 2018
mais on voit pour l'instant calé en
deuxième position derrière le candidat
progressiste conservateur stéphane
sarrazin figure très connue localement
il est le maire d'alfred plantagenet
dans le kingston et les îles les
libéraux sont toujours en avance le
candidat tatsuki à une avance pour
l'instant de 2700 voix sur sa rivale néo
démocrate qui se disent ils donc c'est
un compte et que regagne les libéraux
epn la liste à maclas odiah ministre
sortante des industries du patrimoine du
sport du tourisme et de la culture qui
brigue un sixième mandat qui a une
avance de 500 voix sur son rival libéral
ottawa ouest nepean la néo-démocrate
changera pas se maquiller en avance sur
le député progressiste conservateur
sortant une avance de 106 voix avec 44
voix dépouillées 44 boîte dépouillés sur
70 et que ces séries voilà ça s'était
joué par quelques dizaines de voix en
2018 et c'est encore extrêmement serrée
cette fois ci le classement à
21h39 57 élus 19 en tête pour un total
de 76 chez les progressistes
conservateurs
treize élus 14 candidats en tête on est
à 27 pour le npd trois élus libéraux
sept candidats qui mène total de 10 et
un élu pour le parti vert un nid lui un
candidat pardon indépendant en avance
des résultats maintenant dans la grande
majorité des circonscriptions de
l'ontario 115 sur 124 et regardez sont
ni même au delà pour le moment de la
proportion de votes chez les
conservateurs a obtenu en 2018 on est à
41 pour ça pour le moment 24% pour le
npd 23 chez les libéraux 6 pour la
partie vers 3 pour le nouveau parti bio
de l'ontario et 3 pour pour les autres
partis c'est quand même intéressant de
surveiller sa un des nouvelles de la
colline du parlement face à cette
élection collins parlement la chef
intérimaire des conservateurs à
féliciter d'oxford félicitations à
d'oxford et au parti progressiste
conservateur pour avoir reçu un autre
montage décisif de la population de
l'ontario votre travail acharné votre
compassion et votre leadership
responsable sur le plan financier
serviront bien les ontariens pour les
années à venir également d un tweet de
la part du premier ministre du québec
françois legault qui dit je tiens à
féliciter mon ami doug ford pour sa
réélection à titre de premier ministre
de l'ontario nos gouvernements ont
toujours été proches et ont toujours
collaboré dans l'intérêt des québécois
et des ontariens très entreprennent le
travail retournons maintenant la carte
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
d'action le dans le nord de l'ontario en
ce moment les couleurs qui bascule
notamment dans tes murs où on a pu
confirmer donc un gain pour les
progressistes-conservateurs avec leur
coque d'à vedette le maire de timmins
georges thiéry qui a été élue l'âge et
le buisson qui était député néo
démocrate depuis 1990 qui briguait un
événement d'art il ne leur a pas réussi
soins grosse nouvelle également dans la
circonscription de mojkovac baie james
encore des résultats assez préliminaire
de 99 voix d'avancé pour les
progressistes-conservateurs sur le
néo-démocrate guy bourdin ou guy
bourgoin kg et qui était porte parole
des affaires francophones à queen's park
pour le npd donc c'est des courses c'est
une course très serrée convaincre en
continu de son vaisseau aux six coins de
la province habituellement très néo
démocrate et qui tenteraient de basculer
dans certains cas rendons-nous
d'ingénierie prescott russell oui voilà
d'abord des nouvelles de nouvelles pas
très bonnes pour ce qui est des libéraux
le chef stephen del duca qui est des
faits dans sa propre circonscription on
voyait souvenir dans les sondages dans
les derniers jours les dernières
semaines des conservateurs nous disait
nous allons remporter ce siège là nous
allons abattre monsieur des deux cas
c'est maintenant confirmé michael
thibault l'eau
et qui est là depuis quatre ans qui
remporte à nouveau sa circonscription
alors non seulement pour le moment les
libéraux n'ont pas réussi à augmenter de
beaucoup leur députation mais leur chef
n'est pas n'est pas en avance en fait il
est défait dans sa propre
circonscription
c'est vraiment pas une très bonne soirée
pour les libéraux et je vous écoute
bienvenue sur glengarry prescott russell
qui est toujours en avance pour
l'instant avec 700 voix d' avance sur
amende est simard la libérale encore une
fois stéphane sarrazin qui est très
connu dans la région le maire d'alfred
plantagenet on verra évidemment comment
la soirée va se poursuivre dans ce comté
on va se rendre dans sa circonscription
justement de glengarry prescott russell
rémy oti vous êtes sur place au
rassemblement demanda si mais bon c'est
pas terminé la maymana de ce marquis et
deuxième pour l'instant
absolument et elle a été depuis le début
de la soirée ou presque a eu un trek au
moment où elle avait plus de voix que
son compétiteur monsieur ça rasait pour
l'instant ici on ne sent pas un vent de
panique je vous dirais mais il ya une
attente on espère et à chaque fois
qu'une nouvelle boîte de scrutin qui
rentrent qui comptabilisé eh bien on
voit que l'écart soit se rapetisse de 1
à 2% ou s'élargit de radio pour ça ça
reste encore serré on ne voit pas une
tendance pour l'instant du moins je n'en
ai pas constater ici bien on retient
toujours notre souffle on retient notre
souffle aussi pour un mandat simard qui
avait donné rendez vous à ses partisans
à 21h30 elle n'est toujours pas arrivé à
ce rassemblement mais il ya toujours
quelques personnes qui continuent
d'arriver chaque environ quart d'heure
une deux partisans de plus c'est un très
petit rassemblement c'est assez intime
je vous dirais on nous avait dit que
c'était un rassemblement en mains
privées et on a accepté notre présence
ici mais on espère qu amanda cement
pourra refaire le coup ce qu'elle a
réussi à quatre ans mais cette fois ci
sous les libéraux
la situation est différente le npd n'a
pas été chercher énormément d'appuis
alors c'est vraiment un porte un
portrait très différent ici oui et tout
un symbole en tout cas merci beaucoup
rémy hautil madame simard qui était le
visage de la lutte des francophones
contre ces compressions du gouvernement
de doc fin et qu'il a pour le moment
tirent de l'arrière dans sa
circonscription je crois qu'on parlait
ou au quartier général du parti libéral
de l'ontario bon on était à dix tout à
l'heure le sabé 6 à 8 catherine brulotte
vous êtes quoi avec une organisatrice
puis avec un organisateur du parti
libéral en fait monsieur gabriel italie
vous êtes le joker des politiques pour
le parti ses résultats ce soir qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour le parti libéral
c'est décevant comme résultat c'est on
va continuer à bâtir le parti on va
continuer à appuyer les valeurs
libérales je pense que cette campagne
les gens ne peuvent peser pas attention
on a probablement environ 45% des gens
qui ont voté ce qui est le plus bas taux
de participation pendant l'histoire de
l'ontario à monsieur ford a amené une
campagne ce moment 2 nuls a ils
répondaient pas aux questions des
journalistes ou des gens et
ce quitte votre chef vous avez parlé un
peu plus tôt de son travail au cours de
la campagne on sait pas s'il va même
obtenir son siège ce soit ça semble un
lieu très difficile pour lui qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour monsieur del duca
je pense que stephen a
nous en montrer qu'il sait comment se
débattre c'est une personne qui est
acharnée très intelligent j'étais
vraiment
mes discussions avec lui était
incroyable de coach du côté politique je
suis un ancien fonctionnaire langid
habitude de parler à des ministres et
c'est un des meilleurs avec qui j'ai eu
à faire il connaît bien sa matière et il
peut discuter avec n'importe qui de
beaucoup de sujets quand on a dévoilé
notre plateforme électorale il a pris
des questions des journalistes m'ont en
plus qu'une heure je défie à monsieur
fort de faire cinq minutes où il répond
à des questions il n'est pas capable
pensez vous que monsieur del duca a de
l'avenir comme chef du parti libéral en
ce moment dans le contexte actuel oui je
pense que oui je pense que oui on verra
les résultats dans ce sens si
construction un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'il à
l'avenir de notre parti ça fait deux ans
seulement qu'il est chef il avait une
montagne une énorme montagne à
à monthey et et des résultats 2018 et je
pense qu'on a fait on avait une plate
forme incroyable qui était très détaillé
qui était
on avait tous les coups qui étaient
énumérés et les autres parties n'avaient
pas ça monsieur faure n'avait même pas
une plateforme ce qui est incroyable
tout ce qu'il voulait c'est des
autoroutes pour la reconstruction du
parti de se retrouver à nouveau en
troisième position probablement pas
suffisamment députés pour obtenir le
statut de parti officiel ça met des
bâtons dans les roues ça va être un peu
plus difficile que si on avait le statut
officiel naturellement mais on va qu'une
fille continue à se débattre
on l'a fait depuis les quatre dernières
années on va continuer à le faire si
c'est cali merci beaucoup c'est dire en
soirée alors voilà vous l'avez vu à
quand même la déception auprès des
partisans libéraux qui sont ici les gens
qui espéraient célébrer cette campagne
qu'ils ont menées d'arâches qui font
dire le chef stephen du cas est celui
qui a organisé le plus d'événements
pendant la campagne en tentant de se
faire connaître visiblement avec un
succès mitigé oui voila merci beaucoup
catherine et cet organisateur d'interpol
il nouvelle les nouvelles toutes
fraîches mais monsieur del duca à radio
canada confirme selon les projections
qu'il ne remportera même pas son propre
siège de vendre ou de bridge donc non
seulement les libéraux qui augmente à
peine leurs débuts tu as leur députation
pour le moment mais qui se retrouvent
sans chef en tout cas avec un chef sans
siège à queen's park natacha geneviève
monsieur del duca ce qui peut rester en
poste là avec des résultats comme ceux
qu'on voit ce soir c'est difficile
d'imaginer comment il peut demeurer à la
tête du parti libéral écoutez c'est le
pire résultat pour les libéraux de
l'histoire de ce parti sauf à la
dernière élection il faut même sur le
statut de parti officiel jusqu'ici
pourquoi est-ce que la colère des
ontariens envers kathleen wynne persiste
encore quatre ans plus tard peut-être
est-ce que c'est l'image de monsieur del
du cos est pas le monsieur le plus
charismatique au monde qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour la marque libérale en
ontario au niveau fédéral clairement
qu'elle est encore forte mais au niveau
provincial et c'est quand même
surprenant ce qui n'a pas fonctionné je
dois je pense que deux facteurs le chef
très certainement on a beau dire c'est
une personne qui connaît bien ses
dossiers
c'était un bon gestionnaire mais s'il
n'est pas capable de plaire de parler à
la population
2 et emballé par la politique son
programme c'est difficile de demander
aux gens de voter pour lui plus autre
chose je pense qu'elle une question de
plateformes ou si oui ils ont
retravaillé la plateforme mais ils ont
quand même le faire pas mal les mêmes
propositions que kathleen wynne il y
avait quand même les idées on a parlé
beaucoup du transport en commun dolars a
marqué l'imaginaire on a senti au début
de la campagne en tout cas que c'était
le party qui proposait des nouvelles
distillées libye et plusieurs traits
précis je suis d'accord avec les
personnes avec on a entendu qu'il y
avait une plate forme qui était la plus
développée de tous les partis politiques
tout à fait mais en même temps si les
idées même ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on est à gauche et les libéraux ne
sont pas un parti de gauche c'est parti
de centre et on l'a pas vu alors je
pense que le message c'est pas juste le
chef c'est aussi une question de
centrage de recentrage du parti libéral
à vouloir trop copié puis même le
transport en commun on avait
l'impression que la bière il faut aller
au delà et être soi-même imaginatif pour
dire que les libéraux n'avaient pas
beaucoup d'argent il avait une dette de
10 millions $ payés après 2018 il
n'avait pas l'armée de bénévoles et de
stars politiques là à la sortie d'une
élection d'habitude
les gouvernements de kasserine de
dentine mégane qui comptait sur des
centaines
deux stars politiques pour aller cogner
aux portes pour eux et les avaient pas
ça mais si vous n'avez pas d'argent si
vous avez pas de candidat vous avez
personne qui veut devenir chef à la
place du chef vous avez un problème
c'est que c'est ça qu'on est en train de
voir comme quoi les gens lorsqu'on
revoit t on voit pour des idées oui mais
avant tout pour des personnes et leur
même si le parti avait de bonnes idées
là la personne ne passait peut-être pas
on verra bien ce que ça va être
intéressant de suivre le discours de
steve et d'un duc a tout à l'heure qu'on
nous annonce assez court mais on va vous
le présentez également en direct le
grand toronto phillips et on dit souvent
que c'est là que se font et se défont du
gouvernement parce que ça représente
presque la moitié des circonscriptions
de la province et là c'est encore plus
bleu que ce l'était moins c'est le cas
de le dire en fait les les
progressistes-conservateurs ont raflé
toutes les circonscriptions du 9,05 sauf
oshawa et même à oshawa c'est une course
à césarée en ce moment seulement 331
points vote d' avance pour l'avenir
démocrates en ce moment la grande
victoire pour les progressistes
conservateurs dans le grand toronto
c'est bien sûr brenton je montre d'abord
la carte en 2018 donc ces
circonscriptions là qui était qu avait
été remportée par les néo démocrates en
2018 maintenant c'est devenu bleu et ça
fait mal particulièrement d'emprunter le
centre où c'est le siège de la chef
adjointe du npd ça racing donc andré en
revanche qui perd un peu son bras droit
à queen's park ça va faire mal pour le
caucus néo démocrate
je vous en profite également pour vous
montrer à toronto dans la
circonscription de new york sud-ouest
sun michael ford 9 heures 2 x 2 kg est
en avance bon à une mince avance pour
l'instant messas le l'écart continue de
de s'approfondir donc à york sud ouest n
c'était le néo-démocrate fès al assad
inquiéter députés en 2018 michael fort
de classe est avant cela pour l'instant
alors monsieur x qui grandit son équipe
à queen's park et qui va peut-être
compter sur un membre de sa famille
également à ses côtés on va les
retrouver justement rendre ian williams
qui dans la circonscription de vendre ou
de bridge la circonscription du chef
libéral stephen del duca qui a perdu au
profit des conservateurs andréanne vous
êtes dans le camp des progressistes
conservateurs
[Musique]
oui je vais trop vite et l'absence de
vision humaniste bridge au qg
michael glos qui a remporté 100
l'élection est bonifiée était heureux
également record annoncé lundi pour les
activités que nous les glamies de joie
et a commencé à écrire et à peloter
danger on est très très heureux et du
manque de confiance
j'ai parlé à mes débuts 2
mâcon allez remporter cette élection
hôpital deuxième mandat qu'ils pensent
j'essaie entendre
c'est beaucoup embryonnés à vous voyez
des images en direct de golf le chef du
parti vert mike schreiner qui fait son
entrée mais ce sera un lieu qui
visiblement sera le premier à s'adresser
à ses partisans ce soir les verts qui
pour l'instant ne compte qu'un seul
député le même score qu'en 2018 qui
augmente légèrement leurs suffrages à
peu près 6 % des électeurs qui ont voté
pour les vacances pratiquement 5 pour ça
on va écouter quelques minutes monsieur
choix
ayoye merci à gwen merci goueff qu'elle
ment
[Applaudissements]
le célèbre je veux dire à tout le monde
partout dans la province les personnes
qui se sont levés qui sont sortis pour
être candidat merci d'avoir fait cela
notre démocratie va mieux à cause de
votre service
il ya quatre ans nous lisent avoir fait
de l'histoire à goyave en élisant le
premier représentant du parti vert et
nous avons recréé l'histoire en
réalisant la première personne le
premier candidats qui s'étaient
présentés pour le parti vert et qui a
remporté son siège
oui ont prouvé nous sommes en train de
prouver que les verts sont ici pour
rester nous sommes en train de créer un
momentum dans cette circonscription et
dans toute la province
la soirée s'est j'aimerais dire
muskoka on a une course très serrée qui
a lieu en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous savez de voir un candidat vert qui
est tellement proche tellement proches
en suisse la conscription qui a toujours
été plus par le passé ça vous dit qu'il
y à un momentum vert il y à une vague
verte qui est en train de prendre de
l'ampleur dans cette province s'est pas
seulement un coin fc dans des
circonscriptions dans toute la province
de l'ontario et je veux féliciter malgré
que et toute son équipe pour
l'incroyable campagne électorale qu'ils
ont menées
il
avait appris sa course électorale c'est
trop proche pour savoir ce qui va se
passer en ce moment mais je veux que mal
sa femme et qui ont tellement travaillé
fort et toute son équipe
l'équipe est en train d'amener un
pouvoir du peuple veux que vous sachiez
que nous sommes ici en train de vous
soutenir durant toute la soirée
jung hwan et toutes les personnes qui se
trouvent à quoi vous avez démontré que
nous pouvons faire la politique de
manière différente dans cette province
que nous pouvons travailler de manière
non partisane que nous pouvons mettre
les gens en avant la politique les
gens en premier effet nous pouvons
assurer que nous allons continuer à nous
battre pour que tout le monde est un
endroit confortable où ils peuvent vivre
[Applaudissements]
nous allons investir
dans les travailleurs de la santé qui
s'occupe de nous et que la santé mentale
ça fait aussi partie de la santé est
alors que nous créons des communautés
connectées nous allons lutter pour
arrêter
et pour arrêter que les gens se terrent
fait trop et que nous puissions protéger
les endroits que nous aimons
vous souvenez des petites entreprises
nous assurer que nos communautés soient
prêtes pour le climat et éviter
l'étalement urbain alors je voudrais
prendre un moment pour remercier les
campus vert dans chaque sens
construction de cette province parce que
nous n'avons vu que le vote vert est en
train d'augmenter on l'a vu lors de
cette élection merci pour votre dur
travail
mon projet du candidat de tous les
partis dans tous les sens de ce que
furent construction je vous encourage à
rester engagés et je dis aux autres
candidats ici à boisjean continuons à
travailler ensemble pour créer
la ville ouverte et bienveillante que
nous aimons ici à goyave
[Applaudissements]
d'abord il faut que tout le monde
construit cette bienveillance
l'ontario bienveillant prêt pour la
crise climatique et connectés dont nous
avons besoin leur jeudi une personne de
cette province et de ma communauté
depuis quatre ans
je lui étais très fort pour être votre
voix et je vais continuer à le battre
dans les quatre années à venir pourrait
que le voit d'opposition forte
[Applaudissements]
je me dis
bien certains que les enjeux qui sont
importants pour tout le monde dans
l'ontario qu'on observe pour amener de
l'avant de nouvelles solutions pour la
crise de logement de la santé mentale du
coût de la vie et de l'urgence
climatique
ne vous trompez pas occulter nous allons
continuer à nous battre et à travailler
ensemble à quincy je vais travailler
pour amplifier vos voix parce que nous
devons apporter un changement
particulièrement pour agir sur l'urgence
climatique nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre d'attendre
[Applaudissements]
je veux féliciter monsieur ford
et le parti progressiste conservateur
pour leur victoire ce soir le peuple a
parlé
le peuple a parlé
mais à ce moment critique
à ce moment critique
de cette époque je vous demande de
prendre en compte
3eme bloquer les applications climatique
et que le lait qui financèrent
de mètres du bitume sont les endroits
que nous aimons et sur les terres
agricoles que nous dont nous avons
besoin et la nature qui nous protège
[Applaudissements]
en
tant qu'ancien les inondations les
températures extrêmes et les inondations
les tout ce que nous avons vécu dans le
dernier mois de cette campagne nous
montre ce qui s'en vient pour le futur
de mes enfants et celui des vôtres
alors je vous dis à vous et à mes
collègues de l'opposition que nous
devons travailler ensemble pour nous
assurer que cette province soit prête
que pour les changements climatiques
vous assurer que notre infrastructure
jeu plus supporter les temps fait que
nous avons vécu dans le dernier mois et
pour nous assurer que notre économie
soit après avoir du succès dans les
matchs dans les économies émergentes de
la nouvelle école mais nous devons
travailler pour faire cela parce qu'il
ya trop de choses en jeu
[Applaudissements]
soit moins d'un cube rude alors
j'aimerais conclure en remerciant
avec jimmy ebel jose sharks leader et
danses latines veut célébrer mes héros
climatique ennuis de l'avant un plan
climatique je demande à tous les partis
dans la législature
de voler toutes les idées il faut créer
l'ontario dont nous avons besoin
[Musique]
je vous dis à vous et à tous les
candidats dans toute la province merci
d'avoir partagé notre vision est d'avoir
augmenté notre totale de vote et je
tiens également à féliciter mon
gestionnaire de campagne et sa gouaille
times
[Applaudissements]
une bâtisse meute mais votre gestion de
campagne provinciale qui plus que toute
autre personne a créé le parti vert il a
fait devenir ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as fait à moi et à ma famille ma
femme c'est l'hymne effet isabelle est
bien là et ma maman tu sors merci
tellement de toujours être là pour moi
est avec moi
[Applaudissements]
les vendre du personnel les bénévoles
les candidats les gens c'est elle qui
donne le pouvoir à notre campagne qu'il
donne le moteur de notre campagne aussi
à boire plus profond de mon coeur merci
de rosette du sud pour l'ontario que
vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon engagement que je vais continuer à
travailler très fort pour livrer le
genre de leadership dont nous avons
besoin à tous partent pour être votre
voix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le chef du parti vert match sera
un lieu qui vient de prononcer son
discours monsieur chanut qui encore une
fois sera seul à l'assemblée législative
de l'ontario y avait une course
relativement serré qu'on surveillait
dans périssant muskoka mais où les verts
la termine deuxième la tâche à
chennevières je vous entends de la tude
plusieurs ont dit monsieur je suis
revenu probablement celui qui avait fait
la meilleure performance au débat des
chefs beaucoup d'électeurs ont découvert
dans la campagne mais ça n'a pas levé
beaucoup dans les chiffres comme on
explique ce écoutez monsieur choix et ne
parlait de momentum dans son discours
moi je parlerais plutôt de progression
là on est passé de 4 à 6% des votes
monsieur je suis un gars qui gagne son
siège à nouveau on s'attendait à sa
faute il faut leur donner ils ont fait
tout de même une bonne performance qu'on
en perd autant musicaux cost une énorme
circonscription qui est difficile à
sillonner pour un petit parti qui n'a
pas beaucoup de ressources pas de
candidat libéral dans personnes
jusqu'aux cos c'est la raison pourquoi
ils pensaient qu'ils avaient des chances
mais c'est tout de même un fief
conservateur c'est l'ancienne
circonscription d'un premier ministre
conservateur frank miller donc s'arrêter
difficile pour eux de là à ravir et on
voit que ça pour progresser énormément
c'est à peu près pareil dans tous les
poils les coins de la province une
petite augmentation en termes de
pourcentage mais geneviève monsieur
furieux qui rappelait on va pas veillé
terres agricoles avec l'asphalt ce
fameux projet d'autoroute dont on
parlait tout à l'heure ils ont rappelé
les événements météo extrêmes entre
autres dans la région de tahoua au cours
du dernier mois a dit monsieur ford
garder l'environnement le climat en tête
s'apprêtait facteur 2
s'allumant pas c'est vraiment le facteur
à mon avis l'économie ça et c'était soit
vraiment la principale dimension puis je
pense que monsieur monsieur chenu
malheureusement il le sentait ou ce soir
en disant sur disque où je pourrai pas
vous changé monsieur faure est ce que
vous avez la majorité je peux juste
essayer de vous convaincre massive
convaincre un gouvernement qui si fort
que ça d'après ce qu'on voit avec un
seul député en chambre ait eu de la
difficulté à le faire durant les quatre
dernières années est ce qu'il va être
plus est ce qu'on voit de l'observer
plus on verra mais c'est pas garanti non
plus quel avenir voyez pour ses parties
les partis vers un peu partout on se dit
que maintenant c'est probablement la
période où on parle le plus on dit le
plus conscientisés à des changements
climatiques mais si ça lève pas plus que
ceux d'al les intentions de vote ça va
mal au fédéral on ne vous allez voir du
parti des verts au fédéral on a vu que
les verts ont perdu enfin le npd a gagné
en colombie britannique alors que les
verts et faisait
lorsque le parti était minoritaire le
npd était minoritaire et les verts les
appuyer le npd devenu majoritaire l'élan
qu'on a senti quelques années avec
surtout avec elizabeth may au fédéral
c'est essoufflement données puis comme
pas deux nouveaux porteurs de ballon qui
est là pour dire voici on amène la cause
puis qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement vers le parti de les partis
verts se cherche encore de nos jours
est-ce qu'on va à gauche est-ce qu'on
essaie d'aller chercher des gens de tous
les allégeances politiques monsieur
chien nu pensait l'avoir fait
aujourd'hui avec ferrari 110 coca
s'arrêter une belle victoire s'il avait
eu mais ça c'est pas ça se produira pas
c'est quoi tout à fait arrivée je veux
qu'on revienne aux conservateurs
philippe nous montrer tout à l'heure le
tweak le message de françois legault son
bon ami monsieur faure qui a
soudainement beaucoup de nouveaux amis
depuis depuis quelques années
cette visibilité
extraordinaire qu'on eut des premiers
ministres durant la pandémie des pointes
reims à tous les jours les partis
d'opposition disait tu es si difficile
pour nous de faire notre marque
lorsqu'on veut monsieur ford à tous les
jours devant les caméras c'est la même
chose au québec avec monsieur legault y
aura des élections cet automne c'est
quand même très très difficile pour
d'autres parties de faire leur place
dans ce contexte c'est très difficile
est parti là se sont plaints pour
puisque état est grave c'est que tous
les députés ont travaillé extrêmement
fort pendant la pandémie on leur
demandait de travailler dans leur
circonscription et non pas dans les
assemblées législatives etc ça ils ont
possédé visibilité là alors que les
parties avaient toute la place par
contre il fallait quand même
relativement bien performé parce que
penser à l'alberta par exemple gsm
quelle est alors c'est pas automatique
mais si vous faisiez les bonnes choses
la plupart du temps puis d'ailleurs même
sur ford a admis avoir fait des erreurs
pendant la pandémie et on lui en prenant
pas garder rigueur parce qu'on on
comprenait que c'était difficile à gérer
et donc s'en sortir je pense qu'une
leçon qui est en train de faire en ce
moment au québec avec la prochaine
direction peut-être sa grande force
monsieur fau durant la pandémie
justement ça a été d'admettre ses
erreurs quand on l'a vu pleurer devant
les caméras s'excuser parce qu'ils
avaient fermé les terres injures est ce
qu'on peut imaginer un pierre poilievre
j'estime qu'ils n' y faire pareil
monsieur faure qui aussi qu'ici qui est
pas tombé dans le plat dans le piège des
théories du complot a hélas pas
politiser la pandémie comme d'autres
l'ont fait et c'était un point difficile
pour lui personnellement et la une de
ses filles et une influence euse
anti-vaccins il a parlé à quelques
reprises à quel point c'était difficile
pour lui il est pas tombé dans scary
bord des larmes et basile à une reprise
est ce que ce côté-là eu même s'il ya
des leçons à tirer pour pour d'autres
chefs monsieur fort durant la pandémie
qui admettait ses erreurs mais qui
allait livrer des masques dans des
hôpitaux il y en avait pas qu'ils
sentaient drama les coûts de la
populaire doit être le privilégié qui
lui s'en tire mieux comme pour on avait
l'impression que mes ce qui n' est qu'
un geste qui n'est qu'ils allaient dans
les repas au restaurant oui alors
l'authenticité attrait du terrain puis
d'admettre ses erreurs tous les premiers
ministres ont fait des erreurs durant la
pandémie c'est peut-être pour tout ce
qui est on admire
lorsque vous voyez petite vidéo qu'on
est en train de jouer en ce moment au
quartier général des conservateurs où on
attend nous dit-on dans les prochaines
minutes le discours de victoire de dole
fort de discours qui sera certainement
monsieur fall sera certainement très
très satisfait de la performance ce soir
les conservateurs qui pour l'instant
réussissent à dépasser même le nombre de
députés qu'ils avaient en 2018 on est à
80 en ce moment vous attendez quoi de ce
discours là qu'est ce qui va dire si
vous avez votre boule de cristal
j'aimerais que soient rassembleurs
ce serait ça serait bon de le faire y
est pas obligé de le faire mais bon on
vient de finir une pandémie ça a été
difficile pour tout le monde oui
clairement lui a donné un nouveau mandat
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il peut tout
faire n'importe quoi et donc de tendre
la main sans doute aux autres partis
d'opposition tout en gardant quand même
voici d'autrefois qui fait son entrée
avec sa femme carla on veut vivre ce
moment là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les bleus
merci beaucoup
merci quelle incroyable moment
[Musique]
merci à tout le monde mais quelle soirée
et quels résultats
[Applaudissements]
ensemble on a fait l'impossible nous
avons créé l'histoire soit je suis
tellement reconnaissant tellement
tellement reconnaissants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tout le monde je veux vous
remercier du plus profond de mon coeur
vous remercier d'être ici et pour
remercier de partager ce moment
inoubliable et je vous aime aussi
[Applaudissements]
votre soutien est tellement important
pour moi je vois des visages ici ce soir
des gens qui sont avec ma famille depuis
le premier jour mais ce qui m'emballe le
plus ceux qui réellement me donne de
l'énergie se sont tous les nouveaux
visages que je vois ici
[Applaudissements]
je suis vraiment reconnaissant de votre
soutient depuis de nombreuses années
c'est ce qui me fait continuer à avancer
et aux personnes de l'ontario merci
merci merci merci de votre confiance et
merci d'avoir à nouveau mais votre
confiance en moi c'est une
responsabilité que je ne vais jamais
prendre pour acquis mais très important
merci d'avoir partagé cette vision pour
notre grande province
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partager un rêve d'un futur brillant et
prospère dans un moment de croissance et
d'opportunités sans précédent alors si
vous êtes un miller du nord sans travail
je veux que vous sachiez que nous sommes
en train de créer et de construire cet
hôtel qui va vous permettre d'en avoir
un
[Applaudissements]
vous avez dû vous préoccuper de votre
travail à
une usine de voitures ne sont en train
d'investir dans le futur du secteur de
boîte sera l'ontario si vous êtes un
excitant qui veut travailler dans le
secteur technologique nous aurons un
emploi plupart est en train de vous
attendre
[Applaudissements]
avec le diplôme qui ne peut pas obtenir
du travail dans votre domaine nous
allons vous assurer que vous obtiendrez
les équivalences dont vous avez besoin
c'est ce sur quoi nous travaillons c'est
le rêve de l'ontario et ma promesse et
vous avez ma parole c'est que chaque
jour je vais me lever et je vais
travailler et je vais faire tout ce que
je peux faire pour livrer serait ce
parce que la victoire de ce soir ne
s'agit pas de moi lui même du parti
cette victoire appartient à chaque
travailleur qui sait qu'il mérite mieux
ça appartient à chaque famille qui sait
qu'ils peuvent avoir des grands rêves
mais plus que tout autre chose cette
victoire appartient à chaque à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous
[Applaudissements]
yao à ma femme awa mes belles-filles
toute ma famille
merci de toujours croire en moi et merci
d'être auprès de moi dans les moments
difficiles comme les les bons moments
[Applaudissements]
que je veux remercier toute mon équipe
de campagne et chaque candidat qui se
présente et c'est le plus important
je veux remercier les milliers et
milliers de bénévoles qui ont passé le
dernier mois allé frapper aux portes
ensemble nous avons frappé sur plus de 3
millions de portes lors de cette
campagne
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait incroyable
nous apprend une armée pour gagner la
bataille comme celle ci et c'est super
chiant ce qui de travail qui est
effectué et sachez que ce soit en c'est
votre soi il faut que aussi que je
prends le moment pour reconnaître
l de mark stephens en prend beaucoup
pour mettre son nom de l'avant dans une
course comme celle ci est bien que nous
ayons des idées différentes je crois
réellement que nous partageons le
souhait de voir jeu l'interview réussir
et tous les autres candidats mérites
d'une main d'applaudissements et de mon
côté j'ai fait de mon mieux pour avoir
une importance critique pour mettre de
l'avant un message clair et cohérent
pour faire un flop que tout le monde
pouvait soutenir et je promets de
construire cette province de dire oui à
plus de logement oui à des logements
abordables pour que les familles encore
un fois peuple et se cherchait à
atteindre le rêve d'être des
propriétaires le dire ou es pensera
l'infrastructure qui fait que les
communautés puissent continuer à croître
et qui permet aux travailleurs d'aller
au travail créé les autres construire
les hôpitaux les autoroutes
dans notre province ah si besoin
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir un gouvernement plus intelligent
plus efficace pour qu'on puisse réduire
le fardeau est également réduire la taxe
sur l'essence mes amis c'est un plan que
je met de l'avant et j'ai passé les
dernières cinq semaines à voyager à
chaque point de cette province
rencontrant les hommes et les femmes qui
travaillent si dur à construire
l'ontario et je peux vous dire que nous
sommes prêts l'ontario est prêt prêt à
faire que les choses soient faites
et de réellement prendre cette occasion
faire ce que nous avons le potentiel
d'atteindre de grandes choses nous avons
tous les avantages nous avons des gens
qui travaillent fort nous avons une
abondance de ressources naturelles et
nous avons les minéraux critiques dans
le monde entier pas besoin nous avons le
capital la technologie et l'ingénuité
mais le plus important nous avons la
vision nous devons le rêve je le vois
alors que je regarde la foule
aujourd'hui je le vois dans mon visage
je vois de l'espoir je voie de
l'optimisme et votre énergie votre
passion c'est ça qui me fait me lever à
chaque jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que tout a commencé il ya presque
trois décennies
ici ait un écart de coûts ça a commencé
avec mon père de paul seigneur manama
d'un et mon frère dont l'anniversaire
était la semaine dernière et à qui je
dois tellement
je sais qu'ils sont là au paradis et ses
lèvres avec nous ce soir mes amis ça
commençait avec nous tous et toutes
ensemble
je rends les années on a eu de mauvais
moments de vos moments on a eu des
moments de l'histoire et des échecs à
travers le tout on n'a jamais abandonné
et quand je pense au chemin parcouru
combien nous avons fait de chemin
ensemble nous n'avons commencé qu'en
tant qu'idée une nouvelle approche
pour la politique merci à grâce à toutes
les personnes qui se sont présentées aux
événements qui sont allés de porte à
porte qui ont porté notre message grâce
à vous ce qui a commencé en tant qu'idée
est devenu un mouvement
beaucoup de mouvements politiques qui a
changé le visage de cette province et de
ce pays pour toujours ensemble nous
sommes améliorés imaginez notre parti
notre province près ce soir puis nous
avons changé ce que ça veut dire d'être
progressiste conservateur en ontario
[Applaudissements]
les années il ne s'agit plus de faire
passer ce blouson rouge orange ou sévère
c'est se reconnaître qu'il ya tellement
de choses qui nous unissent
en tant que leader de ce parti je suis
tellement fier de la création de cette
nouvelle coalition de fer prend de
l'expansion notre base créer un parti
plus inclusive où tout le monde est
important parce que jamais dans notre
vie at il été plus important pour partie
de représenter l'ontario dans son
ensemble
maintenant plus que jamais auparavant
il faut punir parce que le chemin devant
nous ne sera pas facile nous avons
beaucoup de défis devant nous on est
dans ce climat incertain ou concurrents
sont donc contre d'autres juridictions
pour chaque emploi pour chaque dollar
investi les l'ontario est plus fort
loulou folk l'inarrêtable lorsque nous
nous unissons à leur ensemble
je dis que je vous demande de vous unir
et que vous souhaitez vous ayez fait que
vous ayez voté pour le nouveau parti
démocratique au pour les libéraux je
veux que vous sachiez que sens que je
suis ici il ya de la place pour vous
dans ce parti
[Applaudissements]
je vais lutter pour voir chaque jour et
mes amis quand je pense aux travailleurs
quand je pense aux syndicats qui nous
ont soutenus lors de cette élection
quand je pense à la coalition que nous
avons créé ensemble
c'est incroyable parce qu'il fut un
moment il ya si longtemps quand
certaines les mêmes personnes qui sont
maintenant avec nous ne se voyait pas
dans cette partie ça n'a pas été facile
nous avons dû admettre nos erreurs nous
avons eu un regard nier leur confiance
et ce cheminement n'est pas terminée je
suis le premier à avouer qu'il ya encore
du travail à effectuer mais le résultat
de ce soir prouve que nous sommes sur le
bon chemin et que cette approche est la
bonne approche et que les résultats de
ce soir où clé c'est la manière dont on
peut réussir à faire les choses en étant
imposé sur notre en centrant sur des
choses qui nous unissent et en étant
prêt à travailler avec tout le monde et
avec cette approche ensemble nous sommes
inarrêtable parce que les neuf ans nous
ne faisons que commencer
baa
johnson ce soir nous allons célébrer
parce que c'est votre soirée ce soir le
peuple a parlé de wendo à cornwall j'ai
même fait merci à mensah agent
ensemble nous savons qu'ils somment
s'entraîne te prendre un nouveau chemin
de son enfant de tir au monde c'est
notre moment parce que c'est notre
province je veux vous remercier et vous
reversez encore et que dieu bénisse les
gens de l'intérieur merci
[Applaudissements]
le premier ministre réélu d'oxford qui
quitte la salle abitibi connor son
rassemblement de campagne discours
rassembleur discours empli d'espoir des
nouvelles toutes fraîches d'ailleurs de
son neveu michael froide avec qui
tentait de se faire élire dans la grande
région de toronto c'est maintenant a
confirmé monsieur ford doc va compter
sur l'appui de son accusation de vue
social vont devoir qui va faire son
entrée à l'assemblée législative de
l'ontario voilà c'est un gain confirmé
pour les conservateurs c'est un peu
l'histoire de cette soirée cité une
circonscription néo-démocrates et ça
bascule maintenant dans la colonne
conservatrice y en a 80 heures pour
l'instant candidat élu ou en avance pour
les conservateurs il ne reste plus
qu'une douzaine de circonscriptions où
il ya toujours des luttes des luttes
qu'on surveille notamment glengarry
prescott russell a marre d'asmar qui est
toujours deuxième pour le moment on ne
dit qu on a regardé des résultats très
bientôt en fait des discours des autres
chefs à venir andrea horvat du npd au
cours des prochaines minutes on attend
toujours des nouvelles des libéraux
steven del duca voici des images en
direct d'hamilton santé l'autobus de
campagne de madame horvat que vous voyez
au fond de la salle
bon ça ne semble pas être la grande
célébration pour le moment on va
attendre de voir ce que madame horvat
aura à dire sur son disco d'abord
d'attaché geneviève parlons de monsieur
x de vos impressions sur son discours
mais écoutez il ya un message qui est
clair net et précis le parti
progressiste conservateur c'est
maintenant le parti de la forte nation
c'est la partie de d'oxford vous
demandiez si la lettre rassembleur avec
son discours oui light et rassembleur il
a parlé aux ontariens la parler aux
électeurs qu'ils voulaient courtiser les
travailleurs de l'automobile les miniers
les nouveaux arrivants il a beaucoup
parlé de sa femme et son frère défend
radford acquis c'est vrai il doit
beaucoup l'on parle la fournée chaîne
il a parlé des parties des autres partis
mais sur seulement pour mentionner les
tranches des électorats qui leur avait
volée
oui vous appréciez dole food vient de
donner une leçon au mouvement
conservateur canadien c'est maintenant
lui le qui est capable d'avoir la
victoire pour un parti conservateur
ce que beaucoup d'autres on tenterait ne
savent pas quoi faire on pense à la
liberté on passe au palais fédéral et le
il a trouvé le temps de trouver le bon
dosage entre un peu populisme pas trouvé
patrice entre inclusif on entend
rarement le mot exclusivité dans le lait
chez les partis conservateur et au
contraire et oui il s'est lui même ce
qui le dis ce soir il s'est lui même qui
est en train de changer transformer le
parti conservateur le mouvement
conservateur canadien au pays voyez
certainement peut-être des leçons pour
les pierre poilievre et compagnie de ski
la retraite ce sont messieurs charest
aussi oui oui
tout à fait parce qu'il a gagné je vais
revenir sur ce que j'ai dit tantôt il ya
quand même 5 % de gens qui ont voté pour
d'autres partis sans doute les deux
parties encore plus à droite le blue
parti et l'interview de partie et l'a
quand même emporté 40 il s'est recentré
un petit peu alors ils prêts à délaisser
les sucs sont vraiment plus à droite
pour dire non moi je me recentre un peu
et c'est là que c'est comme ça que je
vais gagner a dit révolte le qui
disparaissent peut-être les
conservateurs pour l'instant qui ont
plus de vote qu'en 2018 et là ce sont
toujours des images en direct d'hamilton
centre on s'apprête à présenter la chef
du npd andrea horwath je sais pas c'est
elle qui hier qui va faire son entrée
dans la salle je pense que oui on peut
peut-être regarder et écouter ce moment
là on a devancé la morve à 3/10 sur son
avenir à ce qu'elle doit arrêter sa
décision ce soir la partager avec ses
militants à la partager avec la
population
elle est en est à sa quatrième élection
comme chef du npd et le toujours pas
réussi à se faire élire comme un chef du
gouvernement même que cette fois ci a
pas trois élections le npd avait
augmenté son store ou au suffrage en
terme de députés bien là c'est une perte
nette pour bientôt j'y retourne à ce
qu'on avait alors on
les précédentes élections
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour mes amis bonjour les amis
du nord merci tu n'as président pour
cette merveilleuse présentation et pour
tout votre dur travail en tant que
président de notre parti je voudrais
commencer par remercier chaque candidat
du npd qui a mis leur nom sera bulletins
de vote lors de ces élections
littéralement
l'équipe la plus impressionnante de
candidats qui n'a jamais été présent
dans cette province
à la russie le qui vive je n'ai jamais
vu une équipe aussi intelligente avec
autant de réussite ou s'est diversifiée
et aussi dévoué avec autant d'énergie et
autant de possibilités de continuer à
chuter vers l'avant vers l'est vers
l'avant je suis tellement fier de tout
le monde et merci aux milliers et
milliers de personnes qui se sont
portées bénévoles lors de notre campagne
partout en ontario
des milliers de personnes à chaque jour
qui se sont battus lors de notre de nos
campagnes merci beaucoup pour ce travail
si dur
c est en fait et je les ai déjà dit je
le dis depuis quelques jours également
alors que nous traversons la province
vous a littéralement le coeur qui bat de
notre parti et de notre mouvement
vous êtes merveilleux
[Applaudissements]
sean kingston et les incroyables
personnel de campagne
[Musique]
est sûre dans les domaines et au siège
social quelle équipe incroyable une
pomme un applaudissement à eux aussi
merci du plus profond de mon coeur et
vous savez quoi des remerciements tout
spéciaux pour les personnes qui ont voté
pour nos incroyables candidats il y en a
tellement qui ont voté pour nous et pour
de très bonnes raisons parce que ce sont
des quantités incroyables
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors merci merci à vous tous d'avoir
fait que votre bulletin de vote
les tétées pour l'espoir pour
l'optimisme et pour ce que nous pouvons
faire ensemble
c'est qui ce match il merci rui lyon
donc à rien qu'ils ont fait entendre
leur voix lors de ces élections ils ont
vraiment
pour qui vous avez voté merci merci
d'avoir voté merci que que mercy de
démontrer que la province la future est
importante et j'aimerais maintenant
prendre un instant pour remercier steve
george lucas mike schreiner et dr
pour avoir si bien représenter leur
parti chacun chacun qu'il met chaque
personne qui met son nom sur un bulletin
de vote bien de l'avant et rend notre
démocratie plus fort et ça ne fait pas
l'ombre d'un doute
by your browser
mais vous n'êtes probablement pas
surpris de savoir que je ne pourrais pas
être plus fier de la vision que c'est
que nous avons placé devant les
ontariens
d'origine power avec grave nous avons
une vision d'une province où tout le
monde peut avoir les soins de santé dont
ils ont besoin quand ils en ont besoin
et près d'où il risque
[Musique]
un système de santé universel force un
longue
attente ou nous respectons et valorisant
nos incroyables héros des soins de santé
une bonne main d'applaudissement pour
ces personnes-là
non seulement on les respecte mais où on
les soutient
tout comme ils nous soutiennent toujours
non c'est à ce point là on doit
respecter nos travailleurs du domaine de
la santé de première ligne où nous avons
des soins dentaires abordable pour
chaque ontarien
également des soins pour la santé
mentale et de médicaments dans
l'horrible des soins pour les aînés qui
met le respect pour nos êtres chers à la
vendée respect
également une éducation de première
importance dans losange dont besoins nos
enfants un plan pour nous attaquer aux
crises dans le logement et dans
l'abordabilité faire augmenter les
salaires faire baisser les loyers
avoir un nouveau chemin vers l'avant où
on respecte les traités
vous êtes jeunes explique travailler
ensemble avec les peuples autochtones
pour arranger ce qui est brisé que ce
soit des logements abordables ou de
l'eau propre et nous attaquer à la crise
climatique de manière urgente de manière
urgente faire notre part pour nous
assurer que les sept générations
suivantes une et une planète en santé et
un beau futur brillant et plein
d'opportunités
certainement plus pour créer une
province sans sel sans discrimination de
tout genre
oui oui 9 heures nous n'allons jamais
s'arrêter de nous battre pour rendre que
ce soit vrai que ce soit devienne une
réalité pour les gens de l'ontario
dans chaque coin de cette province et
gens comptent sur nous pour être de leur
côté
pour être de leurs portes et une équipe
l'équipe du parti adp qui a été élu
aujourd'hui va travailler très fort à
chaque jour pour vous
à journaux vivent non je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais c'est vrai
c'est le npd et les candidats qui le
représente qui vont toujours se battre
pour chaque personne qui a besoin de
soutien de la part de leurs
gouvernements pour chaque ontarien qui
essaie de créer une meilleure vie pour
eux et pour leurs familles toutes les
personnes qui essaient de créer une base
plus forte les un futur plus brillant
pour la génération qui va suivre
donc ce sport les gens parlent et qu'ils
envoyaient message très clair la
majorité des ontariens n'ont pas soutenu
le gouvernement conservateur
et je voudrais juste dire que le taux
fort doit s'en rendre compte il faut
qu'ils comprennent que les ontariennes
ont pas voté pour avoir plus de coupures
et de privatisations
les choses qui sont les plus importantes
pour nous tous les ontariens n'ont pas
voté pour avoir plus d'atteintes
douloureuse et plus de 8 de plus
le mauvais traitements horribles de nous
être cher de nos aînés ou bien pour que
plus d'écoles de nos enfants
soient abandonnés
et s'écroule ce n'est pas pour ça que
les ontariens ont voté n'ont pas voté
pour que le plus de leurs amis soient
tombés entre les filles est entre les
filets qui vivent d'un chèque de paye à
un autre ou qui deviennent de plus en
plus pauvres et n'ont pas voté pour une
promesse encore boulot et abordable où
les espoirs d'acheter une maison ou de
maine et de joyent est un endroit décent
qu'on peut se permettre devient de plus
en plus seulement un rêve mais magie
majorité des ontariens n'ont pas voté
pour de gros aux autoroutes pour aller
vers de grosses maisons que personne ne
peut se permettre d'acheter
des nouveaux commencements 9 ans ils
n'ont pas voté pour que nos plus
vulnérables soient bloqués dans une
pauvreté législatives n'ont pas voté
pour un gouvernement tous ignorent ces
obligations de traiter ou qu'ils
ignorent
l'augmentation de la haine de la
division et de la
violence qui est présent notamment de
communautés dans notre province et n'ont
pas voté par les parlements clignant la
science
qui fait que la crise climatique en pire
plutôt que de s'améliorer et qui se
débarrasse des terres arables ce sont
les préoccupations que les gens
partagent avec moi depuis des années et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me bats
si fort pour ces personnes-là
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi
respecter les personnes qui faute ça
veut dire écouter tout ce qu'elle nous y
fait c'est une chose
donc qu'il est important de dire avant
ce fruit c'est que de respecter les
personnes qui ont voté c'est d'écouter
tout ce qu'ils nous ont fait alors je
vais donner mes derniers remerciements
pour ma famille et mes amis
et les gens de hamilton
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
je vous aime aussi je vous avancez et
mon engagement envers vous jamais qu'il
va s'arrêter et je vais continuer à
travailler pour mériter votre confiance
à chaque jour je vais continuer à le
faire sans vaciller mais ce soir il est
le temps que je passe le flambeau de te
donner la vie en chine ce nouveau parti
de notre accueil que vous savez ça me
rend triste mais ça me rend heureuse
parce que notre équipe est tellement
fort
je suis heureuse
vous savez j'ai amené un mâchoire et ma
grand-mère normalement est le maître
d'enseignement et je trouve ça mais moi
maman jal est un petit peu bon ça
marchait pas l'enjeu les mig dans ma
ceinture mais je ne pleure pas de
tristesse je pleure de fierté regardez
vous regardez tout le monde qui est ici
regardez ce que nous avons réussi à
faire ensemble
honnêtement ensemble mes amis nous avons
créé un parti qui est plus fort et plus
près de gouverner que jamais auparavant
belga th vous savez on n'est pas arrivés
cette fois ci mais sachez oui sachez que
nous allons continuer à un treuil des
champions puissant dont les gens ont
besoin pour une partie contre les
coupures de doctor who
what et vous savez nous sommes encore
une fois être votre opposition
officielle
alors qu'une guerre ici et je peux vous
garantir
rien en tant qu'opposition officielle
nous allons travailler très fort à
chaque jour pour régler ce qui le plus
important pour les gens de notre
province de l'ontario et vous savez
pourquoi
je leur ai dit vous savez pourquoi nous
avons travaillé si fort parce que vos
priorités sont nos priorités c'était le
cas avant l'élection et elle était lors
de l'élection et elles vont continuer à
être loupé irrité après des lecteurs les
élections parce que c'est ça que nous
sommes en tant que nouveaux démocrates
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais terminer en garantissant un
chapon fait rien que nous allons
toujours toujours travaillé pour vous
merci beaucoup
alors la chef du npd andrea horwath qui
annonce qu elle tire sa révérence ce
soir plusieurs observateurs
s'attendaient à cette décision là après
quatre campagnes électorales madame
horvat qui est député depuis 2004 député
d'hamilton centre qui est à la tête du
parti depuis 2009 ce sera donc une phase
de reconstruction pour le npd également
on va revenir à son discours dans les
prochaines minutes mais d'abord on va se
rendre dans l'est de l'ontario une des
dernières courses qu'on surveillait
celle de glengarry prescott russell avec
nous la députée défaite candidate
défaite à mende asmar qui n'a pas obtenu
un nouveau mandat cette fois pour le
parti libéral dans son management
non sans mettre votre réaction aux
résultats de ce soir c'est certainement
parce que vous attendiez
mais moi je me sens bien parce que je
pense qu'on a une campagne propre une
campagne professionnels on a vraiment
fait tout ce qu'on aurait pu faire avec
mes bénévoles extraordinaires et où tout
au long de notre campagne mais même dans
les dernières années j'ai toujours fait
ce que j'ai cru était la bonne chose et
j'ai été fidèle à mes principes et j'ai
je croyais vraiment que on devait se
tenir debout on devait défendre les
francophones en ontario on devrait
prendre place et lorsque j'ai pris ces
décisions là je n'ai pas pris cette
décision le bret de réélu donc c'était
vraiment des décisions qui étaient
faites
par principe et je savais que ça allait
d un défi d'être élu parce qu'il faut
toujours travaillé extrêmement fort mais
après la campagne qu'on ait eue je pense
qu'on peut en sortir avec la tête haute
on a vraiment bien fait et je très très
fier de mon équipe mon moi je me sens
bien qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
pour vous madame simard on voit deux
chefs d'ailleurs monsieur del duca qui
va prendre la parole dans les prochaines
secondes qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné pour vous et pour la partie
ce soir
je pense que le taux de participation
est très faible et on sait que ça c'est
pas bon pour les libéraux parce que nos
électeurs c'est vraiment bon quand le
tout l'artiste passion et eau pour le
parti libéral de l'ontario donc que je
pense que c'est à une élection qu'on
aime assez si je peux me permettre de
plates et le vote de gauche s'est
divisée quand menacer et monsieur folle
pour quelques raisons a pu se cacher
pendant plusieurs semaines des médias et
éviter les questions merci beaucoup
marot doit vous interrompre
malheureusement on va tenter de venir à
bout dans les prochaines minutes on
écoute maintenant si wendel ducasse
personne
tellement travaillé depuis des semaines
des mois et dans certains cas des amis
qui ont travaillé à m'écouter ma famille
depuis bien des années j'aimerais
remercier les ontariens
pendant un instant nous avons tellement
de chance au canada d'avoir une
démocratie calme en scène et prospère où
chaque voix compte et que ce soit votre
première ou votre 40e élection merci
d'avoir fait votre devoir j'aimerais
également remercier tous les candidats
dans chaque circonscription
que les diables deux reprises auparavant
nous mettre son nom sur un peu de
terrain ce n'est pas une décision facile
à prendre et aller de porte à porte est
allé à des débats les événements et
travaillant pour expliquer ces pointures
expliqué s'additionnent aux gens de
l'intérieur ont également très difficile
et chaque partie de cela prend du
courage je remercie tous les candidats
qui se sont présentés lors de ces
élections
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais dire merci
d'avoir été l'éditeur pour partie
d'avoir fait les sacrifices qui viennent
avec les voyages au travers de la
province pendant des semaines pendant
des mois voire en dur et le fait que
quand on est leader en se faisant
recruter ce n'est pas toujours facile
très souvent on n'est pas d'accord mais
moi je respecte chacun d'entre vous
d'avoir pris votre rôle de leader
je voudrais également remercier et
féliciter
notre équipe libéral de l'ontario pour
femmes ces hommes partout dans cette
relation choisi de se lever et qui ont
choisi de se battre ici fort
je suis incroyablement fier de chacun et
chacune d'entre vous
tous les autres candidats chaque chaque
candidat
[Applaudissements]
notre interview notre parti libéral de
l'ontario notre famille libérale de
fait tellement de chemin très rapidement
et dur à une pandémie
une série de contes et théâtre est
inclusive et diversifiée au sérieux pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de
notre parti 50 cent des candidats et des
candidates
[Applaudissements]
plus jeune est carrément des ternes et à
donner forme au futur de l'ontario
maintenant soyons clairs ce n'est pas le
résultat que nous avions espéré et pour
lequel nous avions travaillé très fort
oui c'est vrai je suis déçu de ne pas
avoir eu de succès ici dans ma
communauté dans ma circonscription
mais je suis très très fier très fier de
tous les députés les membres du caucus
qui vont revenir à la législature
les députés nouvellement élus
je suis fier des idées novatrices que
nous en tant qu'équipe amenant de
l'avant hier qu'à chacune d'entre vous
qui ont fait d'élever son qui est allé
frapper à des portes qui avait fait des
appels qui avait mis des pans qui avait
mis des pancartes et qui aujourd'hui en
fait que les gens
je veux remercier la présidence de
l'association
j'étais député j'ai eu la chance de
servir en tant que président de
l'association de circonscription et j'ai
la chance d'être président du club est
d'être dans plusieurs
effectifs de circonscriptions alors pour
les personnes qui reprennent entre la
base de notre parti oui aux résidents
des centres la mienne que c'est notre
serveur
[Applaudissements]
description aux jeunes libéraux de
l'ontario à l'aps commission des femmes
libérales
tout le conseil c'est que ces partis
vers al de l'ontario merci merci
je
n'ai pas de doute les hommes et les
femmes
que les libéraux de l'ontario
il lui allait du secteur vont faire le
pari encore que ce que leur part pour
faire croître à nouveau mouvement
progressif plein d'énergie ici à
l'ontario compte ce sera un mouvement
qui sera menée par un nouveau leader
plus tôt ce soir j'ai un j'ai informé
notre viande président du parti de ma
décision de quitter leadership et je lui
demandais de faire une réunion avec les
membres de l'exécutif pour faire le
nouveau choix aussi rapidement que
passer bien encore une fois je suis
tellement fier du travail que nous avons
effectué et une autre chose que je sais
voir comment nous avions
et commença devenus plus forts que nous
avons travaillé tellement fort pour
construire ce parti depuis quelques
années je sais que nous en tant qu elle
famille politique et en tant que
mouvement politique
nous allons commencer la prochaine
campagne d'un pierre maille à l'endroit
de nous en plus ces nouveaux députés que
nous avons montrent ajouté nous avons
fait venir
de milliers de nouveaux bénévoles et
membres du parti pour continuer à lutter
et nous anticipons que le parti sera
sans tête d'ici la fin de l'année
[Applaudissements]
important je sais que les libéraux de
l'ontario vont utiliser notre nouvelle
plateforme plus fort pour continuer à
proposer des idées innovatrices et de
votre récit progresse bien pensé pour
faire que notre province soit l'endroit
où on peut croître aujourd'hui
de la province a parlé et ont donné un
gouvernement majoritaire conservateur
j'aimerais féliciter le premier district
j'espère qu'il sera un bon leader pour
la province chelsea et je le dis
sincèrement parce que mais par dessus
tout je suis un père sa taille abri
grèce qui sont assez ici et je veux que
mes filles puissent grandir dans ce
nombre de provinces
l'ontario incroyable qui leur offrir
encore plus d'opportunités que moi j'ai
eu un grand du ca ici
c'est la responsabilité incroyable
d'être le leader de cette grande
province
à être une grande responsabilité
c'est que ce serait pour moi parce que
c'est important d'avoir entre les mains
les rêves et les espoirs de millions de
personnes et en tant que parti nous
allons nous encore doubler votre
confiance pour avoir notre confiance
parce que pour nous ce n'est pas
important d'où vous venez de vous est
arrivé avec qui vous êtes connecté
combien d'argent vous la gym quel est
votre wii sociale ce qui est important
pour nous c'est que vous sentirez celui
que vous sentiez inclus tu veux que vous
sentiez vue
regardez importe où vous vivez le nord
le sud que vous soyez l'indien auzeral
douce irish ou pas nous allons nous
assurer que vous ayez lâche votre chance
de réussir c'est enfin ce que nous
voyons et c'est le genre dans thériault
pour lequel nous allons toujours nous
battre
un dieu un dieu
forte et jamais nous n'arrêterons de
travailler pour que ceci est la dernière
chose que j'aimerais de dire en
terminant c'est qu'il ya énormément de
personnes et j'en vois beaucoup
alors que je suis ici sur ce podium et
je sais je sais que vous dans cette
salle représenter des milliers d'autres
personnes partout et notamment les
hommes et les femmes qui jamais ne sont
heureusement à l'avant sera posée mais
ne voit jamais leur nom dans un journal
intime et moi et chacun de nos candidats
nous sommes sur vos épaules
sont très importants pour nous ni pour
moi ni rien car il y ma femme et nos
filles
[Applaudissements]
ma femme et nos deux filles que j'aime
d'etel 1 qui m'ont inspiré mais qui
meurent aussi qui me soutient à chaque
étape une forme et je peux confirmer que
nous sommes déjà d'accord nous allons
aller à la jeunesse pas
[Applaudissements]
fait si la raison pour laquelle chose
faite ou les raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai toujours est en mesure de refaire
ce que j'ai essayé très fort le faire
il ya d'autres personnes que j'aime
remercie également qu'il ne se trouve
pas dans la salle mais qui sont en cause
mais ce sont mes parents marc et marie
elise lucet vous fait
mahmoud abbas est devenu tellement
souvent rimé littéralement ils ont tout
fait pour moi
pour mes frères vous là ça ils sont tout
fait pour nous se sont sacrifiés
ont travaillé tellement fort et continue
à le faire je veux dire maman papa je
vous aime tellement et je suis tellement
reconnaissant pour tout ce que vous avez
toujours fait pour moi merci
en somme on a faim un homme je veux
également remercier
non
je regarde ici les gens qui je le sais
on
notre jeu c'est la vôtre en panne des
systèmes en réseau
[Applaudissements]
je commence à lire le nom de toutes
époques sans travailler de rester dans
les dernières quatre chemins et comme
dans certains cas comment c'est quand
même un signe depuis 30 ans
mais je te remercie tous envie je veux
vous remercier d'être adéquat à chaque
chat un chat même incroyable pour moi
dans ces chats mais pas les policiers
que j'avais seulement le plan juridique
c'est tout
je sais que jamais nous allons affecter
le travail je sais que nous allons
continuer de croître au delà
d'être une force du bien pour le
champion consultant notarié c'est ce que
font les libéraux de l'ontario et c'est
ce que nous faisons bien c'est ce que
nous devrions continuer à faire et je
sais que nous allons le faire et je
voudrais simplement dire qu'il ya eu la
chance depuis quelques années le servir
en tant que votre militaire a été
l'honneur de même je veux vous remercier
je veux remercier tous les membres du
parti libéral de l'ontario de me donner
cette opportunité de travail il faut
mener une ferait de moi il devrait
assurer que nous puissions toujours
mettre notre meilleure de la ligue alors
merci qu'il faut le croire merci de
votre incroyable merci de toujours être
là pour moi et les bras de fer
est créé à l'interview qui sera toujours
en sort
grandie merci
steven del duca et qui a mené son parti
le parti libéral au cours des deux
dernières années qui était en poste
depuis juste juste avant la pandémie qui
quitte donc la direction du parti
libéral de l'ontario c'est quand même
pas rien de ce qui vient de se passer
d'eux des chefs de partis d'opposition
qui ont annoncé qu'ils quittent leurs
fonctions dans la dernière demi heure on
va prendre le temps si vous voulez bien
de décanter tout ça geneviève natation
ou le dit un peu plus tôt avec les
résultats qu'on voit ce soir huit
députés il y en avait ce site la
dernière fois la pire performance de
l'histoire délibérons voyait pas trop
quand même se dire de quoi pouvait
rester impossible pour lui de rester
chez eux ils n'auraient pas été capables
de convaincre les membres de son parti
qu'il méritait de rester après la
performance de ce soir ça a été
impossible aussi de convaincre l'un des
huit députés de lui donner son siège
quand le seul point positif du discours
du chef c'est de dire que on à
rembourser notre dette de 10 millions de
dollars là y'a pas grand chose à
célébrer et il ya la perte d'un mandat
ce mardi veut veut pas c'est une perte
pour la francophonie le parti libéral
avec le npd mais le parti libéral avait
fait beaucoup pour les dossiers
francophones ces dernières années était
vu comme le parti qui représentait cette
communauté là et là c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de francophones ce
soir avec les résultats qu'on est là qui
n'ont pas voté pour les libéraux
clairement là donc c'est plus vus par
les francophones comme nécessairement le
parti qui va les défendre c'est ça on
verra monsieur fouad a quand même fait
ses classes depuis depuis quelques temps
puis dans un sondage qui avait été
publié quelques temps on voyait que les
questions francophones étaient en mode
la liste pour parce que c'est
préoccupait pas mais c'est parce qu'on
sait que c'est tellement difficile
aigle et que d'autres problèmes à régler
comme la santé l'économie mais toute la
question de l'éducation
l'immigration
la santé c'est très complexe mais on se
rend compte qu'on réglera possible
demain matin je pense que c'est un peu
par défaut qu'on dit bon on va voter sur
d'autres dossiers plutôt que la
francophonie veut pouvoir attendre un
peu moi j'ai reçu plusieurs appels de
libéraux et de néo démocrates pas
content des résultats du sondage ipsos
radio canada mais puisqu'un sondage a
démontré puisque les résultats de ce
soir des mondes peut-être que les
franco-ontariens ils votent pas beaucoup
différemment des ontariens en général à
les ontariens ont choisi mon à 40% 40 40
40 bien pour ça d'oxford ce soir là et
c'est pourquoi ce serait différent
là-bas exactement et les francophones
mais on y est on y est et rocklyn là on
n'est pas en forme chanson
glengarry face à personne de mon très
bien
l'état dit regardons la performance en
termes de suffrages des libéraux parce
que lui en termes de sièges sera pas
augmenté mais ils ont récolté quand même
24% des votes ce soir c'était 19% 2018
donc a quand même une personne sur
quatre qui est allé vote aujourd'hui qui
a voté pour les libéraux c'est plus
forts évidemment dans l'est un peu plus
faible dans le centre et dans le nord le
grand toronto quand même 31 % c'est que
certains sièges qui ont changé de
couleurs à la faveur des libéraux dans
ce conte est là à partir de maintenant
comment on reconstruit ce ce parti là et
avec qui on va voir qui est intéressé
par la motion il sas ne se bousculait
pas la dernière fois
on voit que c'est un grand parti
effectivement avec le vote populaire
c'est pas un parti qui va disparaître
demain matin il ya quelque chose à faire
avec ce parti là mais ce que le parti
prend la bonne direction en ce moment
après deux défaites importantes
on doit sans doute se dire bon il faut
amener le parti yahia il ya très
certainement des gens qui peuvent le
faire est-ce qu'ils ont un goût de le
faire parce qu'ils ont un goût de faire
à ce moment aussi où un d'oxford est si
fort en ce moment
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils ont
quatre ans c'est ce que j'allais dire on
a quatre à partir de maintenant pour eux
mais il ya une réflexion à faire au sein
du parti libéral parce que là on a aussi
poussé vers la gauche et on a laissé le
centre grand ouvert pour d'oxford qui
seul est accaparé ya deux ans on a
choisi un chef qui représente l héritage
de cas chez nous et son ancien ministre
des transports quand même ça ça lui a
collé à la peau j'avais perdu son siège
en vente le bridge le parvis 1000 voire
donc c'était un choix singulier qui
représentait un peu la continuité alors
qu'il y avait d'autres candidatures
intéressantes dans cette course à
l'investiture je pense à makoto par
exemple qui est aujourd'hui député
fédéral dans la même circonscription
attaque que si si c'est lui qui avait
été choisi en aurait un un résultat
différent ce soir je sais vous
connaissez tous les candidats et
candidates au fond de votre poche et
scott des parmi les huit le cd peut-être
des gens qui lèverait la main pour pour
aller à la chefferie ou faut aller piger
à l'extérieur pour
lui elle s'était présentée la dernière
fois est ce que ce serait la bonne foi
elle pourrait être intéressée à ce que
c'est la réponse à avoir parce que c'est
pour le bien du parti sas était fanny
bon mène dans deux vallées ouest qui
était une candidate
d'être je crois que c'était une venaient
du secteur bancaire le bien respectée
dans le monde des affaires de toronto
elle aussi sa pourrais tu ne signes sont
la solution de chat à madrid l'ancien
premier ministre qui rebascule dans le
cas dans le camp des libéraux ce soit
stéphanie baume une qui remporte john
valley ouest bon l'autre départ
auquel on s'attendait également le
meilleur c'est venu quand même assez
vite assez vite celui de madame va très
très ému on peut le comprendre quand ça
fait 13 ans qu'on est à la tête de son
parti elle a raison de dire qu'elle a
amené le parti elle le fait progresser
le parti c'est à dire que c'est la
deuxième élection le npd est quand même
l'opposition officielle c'est pas rien
sur sa forme maintenant est une force
importante dans la province on parle
souvent de est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
réunification de la gauche à ce que les
libéraux puis le npd éventuellement
deviendra un seul parti je pense que ça
va réveiller demain matin mais si
c'était le cas c'est le npd qui
ressortirait gang ans hélène [ __ ] curé
était capable de faire ça et donc elle
le fait beaucoup pour le parti mais en
même temps je pense que la plupart des
gens en conviennent qui était temps
qu'un pas le fait qu'elle annonce ce
soir ça vient de régler bien des
problèmes
ça vient aider le parti c'est pas rien
ce qu'elle vient de faire mais c'est
crif car en même temps d'arracher le
tout dans ce faux dur et difficile de ne
pas être touché tout de même en par ce
discours où il y avait des rires qui se
faufilait entre les larmes d'un mauvais
oeil j'ai eu la classe quand même en
d'aller féliciter ses adversaires qui
ont eu lumidee l'humilité de dire
écoutez ces montants il faut que je
passe la torche donc ça va être
intéressant de voir justement qui va
succéder à madame horvat parce que comme
vous le dites ils sont dans l'opposition
officielle et donc il va falloir choisir
une succession assez rapidement mais ce
fait de quatre ans devant lui l' et
l'aja lady bon avec un gouvernement
majoritaire de toutes façons de les
coudées franches pour faire ce qu'on
veut mais avec deux partis d'opposition
sans chef monsieur faure peut faire à
peu près ce qu'il veut au moins pour la
prochaine année oui et ça va être sens
avec le danger pour lui c'est de trop
faire ce qu'il veut il suscité la grogne
est ce qu'on revient à la première année
de son premier mandat c'est pas
impossible non plus parce qu'avec la
performance qu'il a ce soir et nous le
dit déjà le budget a été adopté
rapidement tout va se mettre en place
peut-être que marc franusch finalement
avoir refusé parce que je pensais
taillon qui se retrouvent seules la
seule opposition
chef qui ne sont pas après deux fois et
qui connaît les dossiers et donc et qui
peut s'occuper des dossiers alors que
tous les autres membres l'attention à
une course à la chefferie qui va être
une très grosse distraction à l'homme
promet se fera fort c'est vraiment les
coudées franches avec ces récompenses
mais son lot de pièges aussi vivement
qu'il fasse attention par la demande à
ciment tout à l'heure des fêtes porte
parole entre visage de la communauté
francophone gilles bisson également dans
le nord de l'ontario pour le npd sont
mobiles et ligne de parti de l'est parce
que les francophones perdent perdre des
voix connaissent pas que ce soit oui
deux voies importantes très certainement
qui connaissait très bien les dossiers
et qui étaient là pour rappeler les
dossiers toujours les amener à l'avancé
oui c'est les grosses pertes monsieur
buisson là philippe le disait c'était le
doyen de l'assemblée législative c'est
une voix forte dans le caucus
francophone du npd monsieur buisson
c'est un peu une défaite crève coeur il
a subi un infarctus infarctus assez
sévère tout juste avant la campagne moi
je suis allé je suis passé par artemis
justement je suis allé le voir lui
faisait du porte-à-porte avoir de son
véhicule c'était pas facile donc fort
qu'ils arrêtaient pas d'aléa wings
d'aller à thémines jouer pour aller
encourager son candidat donc défaite
crève coeur
les francophones geneviève on parlait du
spectre il ya quatre ans les
compressions dans le gouvernement de
monsieur ford dit dans son discours oui
on est dans dix périodes économiques
difficiles
est ce qu'on doit craindre qu'on soit
francophone nous parle de budget un peu
plus des budgets un peu plus austère
éventuellement si des cop éventuellement
oui je pense que j'ai vu ce que ça
donnait pas ce que je vais surveiller
attentivement ses carreaux les demandes
ronnie est ce qu'elle conserve le
portefeuille de la francophonie si oui
c'est des bonnes nouvelles parce qu'elle
connaît très bien le dossier
une bonne porte parole de la communauté
franco ontarienne est donc ça ça va nous
aider mais ce choix et des pois
antifrancophone par ailleurs là alors
il a compris quelque chose qu'il n'avait
pas saisi aux quatre ans le travail est
déjà fait mais est-ce que ça va devenir
un peu plus secondaires c'est possible
parce que justement avec cette grande
victoire là les comptes et francophones
qui pouvait faire la différence mais ont
peu fait la différence ce soir vous
ouvre une belle porte sur une éventuelle
conseil des ministres de d'oxford
plusieurs de ceux qui étaient à ses
côtés sont réélus ce soit il y en a même
d'autres à la malraux nice en est un
exemple qui on voit ce qu'on voit de
grands changements le parlement va
reprendre une grande question c'est qui
vont être le ou la ministre de la santé
avec le départ de christine elia qui
était bon son bras droit la vice
première ministre
il ya des noms qui flottent en ce moment
a servi à jaws notamment un soliste en
général qui a piloté la distribution des
vaccins en ontario pour absar carrière
jeune ministre ambitieux qui est au
conseil du trésor ça va être intéressant
de voir qui qui va remplir ses
chaussures ses grosses pointures quand
la recette fonctionne aujourd'hui parce
qu'on change c'est ce qui va être
intéressant je m'attends à ce que d'un
creux garde pas mal sa garde rapprochée
c'est je pense qui fidèle à son équipe
un peu comme justin trudeau d'ailleurs
et là on va voir s'il veut brasser les
cartes ou non alors je m'attends au même
mine et des finances la ministre de
l'éducation pas beaucoup de changement
la halle et plusieurs la continuté
djordje prix d'ailleurs le maire était
mis à gagner ce soir lui on pourrait le
voir au cabinet des ministres un mois
que 112 qui était un candidat vedette
lui le perdu dans toronto si l'ancien
chef de police de toronto on le voyait
d'ailleurs au conseil des ministres mais
ça n'arrivera pas cessons de vue
oui ça va être intéressant effectivement
bon ça fait partie des histoires de
cette soirée électorale et deux départs
chez le npd et chez les libéraux l'autre
histoire à laquelle personne ne
s'attendait l'on participe à des
réunions pour préparer des soirées
électorales il ya personne qui avait vu
venir l'élection bienvenus deux d'entre
eux optez indépendant un résultat
inhabituel justement d'ordino le phoque
dans le sud-ouest donc une candidate
indépendante qui gagne bobby and ready
qui gagne qui a une avance sur le
candidat progressiste conservateur un
résultat surprenant dans un château fort
conservateur mais où le député
progressiste conservateur sortant toby
berit ne se représentait pas le parti
avait misé sur gamecube pour qui est
maire du comté de audi mène pour le
remplacer c'est une stratégie qu'on a vu
justement les progressistes
conservateurs utilisés souvent ça a payé
dans d'autres cas comme glengarry
prescott façon justement dans timmins
aussi mais ça n'a pas marché dans ce cas
si bobby anobli dit qu'on va devoir
apprendre à connaître qui est une ex
journaliste et qui a aussi en fait
travaillé au bureau de tarbes ibérique
et c'est une nouvelle venue à queen's
park nouvelle venue à queen's park ont
dit que ça fait depuis
1995 qui a pas eu d'élection des députés
indépendants ça fait quand même un petit
bouddha en ontario on poursuit avec
d'autres réélection
ou le procureur général sortant d'abord
ni se bat tout ça c'est fini la bonne
alchimie ce n'est pas fini donc en
deuxième position il ya le maire de
berry jeff l'hymen qui est qui en fait
candidat libéral pour l'instant une
avance de d'abdos ni pour l'instant de
582 voix avec deux boîtes qui restent à
dépouiller il ya six circonscriptions
pour le moment où la lutte n'est pas
terminée
c'est pas mal joué partout et on est dès
maintenant des résultats dans les 124
circonscriptions de la province je vous
disais qu'il y avait certains bureaux de
vote qui restait ouvert un peu plus
longtemps maintenant on a commencé le
dépouillement partout belle occasion
d'aller vous voir philippe avec la carte
électorale qui complète ce soit et
complète en ce moment et où j'ai attiré
votre attention vers le nord de
l'ontario parce qu'il ya eu deux gains
des progressistes-conservateurs je vais
vous montrer d'abord la carte du nord en
2018 où il y avait un bout en bout
rouges ont le libre les libéraux qui
sont complètement rayé du nord de
l'ontario donc c'est un gain néo
démocrates mais somme toute pour le net
les néo démocrates ont perdu un siège
avec timmins et puis tampa bay atikokan
de batiscan qui est une un gain des
progressistes-conservateurs
kevin hollande qui remporte ce siège là
on vient juste de voir des couleurs qui
se sont ajoutés l'ajustement des néo
démocrates ont conservé leur siège oui
alors c'est pas mal le bleu bleu dans le
centre et le sud de l'ontario l'est de
l'ontario et c'est pas mal orange et
dans le nord malgré certains changements
on va les voir myriam et d'ailleurs qui
souvenez vous si vous êtes à l'écouté
avec mon topic début qui suivait cette
campagne cette soirée électorale en
compagnie d'une famille de la région de
waterloo
avec différentes allégeances politiques
qui est ce que les gens pensent des
résultats miam
il y en ad content il y en ad - comptant
d'abord sami c'est la première fois
qu'il a voté 18 ans vous êtes un peu
triste mais je vous ai vu un petit peu
sous père et comment vous réagissez oui
je suis déçu que le gouvernement fera
gagner un gouvernement majoritaire parce
que je suis contre ses positions sur
plusieurs enjeux et mais je suis
également déçu que son parti les
progressistes-conservateurs ont gagné
une majorité des sièges faut savoir
gagner une majorité des voix et de
l'autre côté on à jacob l'ami de samy 19
ans jacob vous vous êtes satisfait de la
campagne des progressistes conservateurs
oui absolument je trouve que le
gouvernement fort qui ont bien fait leur
campagne ils ont laissé tomber
l'idéologie et les pyromanes les
promesses grand dios tendu et ils y ont
fait leurs campagnes sur le progrès
tandis que leurs concurrents se trouvait
plus à faire de grandes idées et de
moins d'action je parlais aussi au père
de la famille a5 plus tôt plus tôt
aujourd'hui lui c'est sans surprise que
d'oxford a été réélu est ce que c'est
une bonne idée est ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour lui est bien lui il
était plutôt du parti libéral donc c'est
une déception de ce côté là aussi vous
voyez que les opinions divergent dans
une même famille dans un même le cercle
c'est peut-être le cas pour vous à la
maison ils ont suivi la campagne
électorale et la soirée avec vous
laisse entendre les critiques merci
beaucoup myriam
alors faire un petit tour dans la région
d'ottawa où il ya eu certains
bouleversements certains changements
fiona quel est le portrait de les gens
chez vous
ce qu'on peut dire mathieu ottawa c'est
quand même que les libéraux ont réussi à
conserver certaines circonscriptions
vraiment château fort en place ici à
ottawa vanier où je me trouve aussi à
orléans ou encore à ottawa reçues donc
ça pour eux ça peut être en quelque
sorte effectivement rassurant ce qui est
fait aussi c'est que le npd a réussi à
conserver ottawa sens où on essayait de
voir ce qu'elle est ce passé là bas le
npd a aussi fait un gain juste à côté
dans la circonscription de west nepean
où il avait une bataille très serrée
avec les conservateurs et puis
globalement si on recule un peu qu'on
regarde là là car plus au sud et à
l'ouest et conservateurs sont quand même
encore très présent et gardent aussi
leurs bases solides dans la région donc
je dirais que les libéraux pour passer
une soirée difficile décevante à
l'échelle provinciale peuvent peut-être
un tout petit peu spéciaux les sur la
région d'ottawa en garde quelques bases
et la députée qui est reconduite et
cyril collard me disais que pour elle
évidemment ça montre est quand même
qu'ils avaient un lien plus fort entre
les libéraux et ottawa petite
consolation peut être pour eux autres
évidemment un grand résultat dans notre
région dans l'est ontarien c'est ce qui
s'est passé ce soir glenn de rue près
stable au sort vous en avez beaucoup
parlé mais je me rappelle la députée
amanda simard a été défaite ce soir on
regarde évidemment cette course avec
beaucoup d'attention elle était passée
des progressistes conservateurs libéraux
lors de la dernière législature mais
elle n'a pas réussi son pari et c'est
stéphane sarrazin qui le remporte ce
soir donc voilà je voudrais que la caf
rappelle un petit peu changé d un gain
mpd d'un gain aussi conservateur et puis
des libéraux qui quand même sont heureux
dans cette salle 6 même si le contexte
global mais pas vraiment positif pour
eux à ottawa on se console un petit peu
et comment vous avez par la madame
colère tout à l'heure est ce qu'il ya
une explication quelconque pour la
déconfiture du parti la suite des
championnats
je dirais qu'elle était très prudente
dans sa réponse à ce moment là on ne
savait pas encore aussi cochet fallait
partir elle disait qu on va devoir
analyser les choses elle se disait
elle-même étonnée déçu et étonné par ce
qu'elle dit on avait été rencontré les
ontariens on l'avait aussi l'impression
que valve acceptent qu'ils avaient un
meilleur meilleur accueil peut-être
cette fois-ci elle dit clairement une
chose qui ne s'est pas bien passé et je
vous dirais que c'était vraiment l'idée
va analyser les choses voilà une
victoire quand même douce amère
évidemment pour elle dans ce contexte-là
oui voilà on peut comprendre que
beaucoup de réflexion qui sent vieillir
chez les libéraux entre autres merci
beaucoup fiona collienne dans la
circonscription d'ottawa-vanier ce soir
on va retourner voir nos collègues
reporter dans les permanences des des
différents partis donc catherine
brulotte camif et résines camille guy
roy mathieu simon va commencer avec vous
qu'à me faire et zen chez les verts
bilan de la soirée monsieur schreiner
qui regagne son siège mais qu'il n'a pas
de d'autres d'autres amis du parti vert
avec lui
ouais une sorte de résultats en
demi-teinte je vous dirais ici alors on
est très contents que may cry murray
remporter à nouveau son siège à gouel
favec un très bon résultat à près de 55%
des votes c'est près de 10% de plus que
ce qu'il avait remporté en 2018 avec
près de 45 % des votes j'ai parlé un peu
plus tôt avec mike schreiner justement
et deux de ses partisans qui me disaient
qu'ils étaient satisfaits de ce résultat
aussi le fait que le vote envers les
verts le vote populaire a aussi augmenté
on en est à environ 6% en 2018 on en
était à 4,6 pour cent donc le vote
populaire augmentent ils voient ça d'un
bon augure ils voient que c'est la façon
de finalement bâtir ses actes lui à
queen's park bien entendu une déception
au s'il aurait aimé avoir un collègue
vers à ses côtés un match winner à
l'assemblée législative de l'ontario ça
ne va pas être le cas puisque la
circonscription tant convoité de paris
sans de muskoka et bien revient au
candidat progressiste conservateur en le
maire sortant de bracebridge graydon
smith donc une déception de ce côté là
mais mike schreiner me parlait toujours
de son un momentum en me disant que je
lai les continuer à bâtir ses acquis
qu'il allait continuer à représenter ses
électeurs à queen's park il espère bien
continuer sur cette voie et m'a dit
finalement comme rome ne s'est pas bâtie
en un jour et ben être un quatrième
parti en ontario ça ne se fait pas tout
seul il faut y aller petit à petit
progressivement mais sûrement oui c'est
ce qui se produit avec les verts pas de
nouveaux députés mais un petit
augmentation dans le vote populaire ce
soir merci camille on va se déplacer
chez les libéraux catherine brulotte
plusieurs attendaient le discours de
stephen del duca qui n'est plus chef
depuis une demi-heure environ du parti
la réaction que vous ont dit les gens
dans son entourage
disons que ça me fait très abruptement
au rassemblement si du côté de gilbert
il faut dire que tout au long de la
soirée lorsqu'on voyait les chiffres
commençaient à sortir le nombre de
députés possible probable et même
finalement élu pour les libéraux
n'étaient que des déceptions les gens se
sont fait beaucoup d'accolades parce
qu'il faut savoir que même au sein du
parti parmi les organisateurs on en
avait un peu plus tôt avec nous
aujourd'hui les gens espéraient au moins
que le chef obtienne son siège et qu'il
puisse continuer son travail dans cette
reconstruction du parti libéral mais
voilà ce type un netbook à qui a perdu
également dans woodbridge d'en vendre
bridge dis-je et qui donc a choisi de
quitter le leadership du parti ce sera
une reconstruction difficile nous disent
les organisateurs du parti une
reconstruction aussi laborieuse en
raison de la position des libéraux
maintenant queen's park toujours comme
troisième partie toujours avec un nombre
insuffisant de députés pour être un
parti officiellement reconnue donc une
tâche importante qui se trouve devant
les troupes libérales qui devront donc
trouver un moyen de regagner le coeur
des électeurs
revenir dans la conversation publique et
peut-être il l'espère du moins faire
mieux dans quatre oui oui oui faire
mieux dans quatre ans c'est ce qu'on se
dit cette fois ci les libéraux allaient
peut-être faire mieux c'est pas
nécessairement beaucoup mieux merci
beaucoup catherine poursuivons notre
tournée camille guy roy avec le npd
départ aussi de madame horvat bon ça on
sentait que ça s'en venait mais dans les
deux camps se disent que ça va vraiment
arriver ce soir ou est-ce que
les chefs vont se donner un petit moment
de réflexion là aussi c'est tombé madame
horvat qui était très émotive
oui madame en fait qui a annoncé son
départ qu'elle passait le flambeau avec
émotion mais en même temps il a dit ses
larmes que vous voyez c'est pas
nécessairement des larmes de tristesse
mais aussi des larmes de joie parce que
je laisse derrière moi une équipe forte
c'est vraiment son message que le npd en
fait elle a parlé des progrès que son
parti a fait et de la voix qui s'avance
qui s'annonce devant elle pour son parti
et surtout en tant qu'opposition
officielle parce qu'elle va contre le
npd va conserver ce rôle d'opposition
officielle face à des fraudes est
d'ailleurs madame en fait qui a
également dit dans son discours
attention monsieur ford s'était pas la
majorité des ontariens qui ont voté pour
vous ce soir parce qu'on parle d'environ
un peu plus de 40 pour cent du vote
populaire pour les progressistes
conservateurs
alors elle a lancé ce message qu' il
faut pas se reposer sur ses lauriers
pour l'équipe de mr ford m'a d'abord
fait qui a aussi rappelé en fait là la
vision que le npd avait mis de l'avant
dans cette campagne avec des grands
programmes sociaux notamment en santé
elle avait proposé l'assurance
médicaments l'assurance dentaire l'accès
universel à des services de santé
mentale et ça c'est vraiment des
éléments sur lequel elle veut continuer
de mettre l'accent fait son équipe d'une
[ __ ] va continuer de mettre l'accent même
si c'est pas elle nécessairement qui
sera à la tête de ce parti donc une
course à la direction qui va bientôt
s'amorcer ça va être intéressant de voir
les noms qui vont se présenter pour
cette course à la direction est
d'ailleurs une parce qu'il ya plusieurs
plusieurs députés sortants qui ont perdu
leur siège ce soir et je vous mentionne
notamment sa racine dans bronson qui
étaient là dès la chef adjointe de ce
parti qui a perdu son siège ce soir
alors qu'on la voyait quand même comme
une étoile montante de ce parti alors à
voir qui va mettre son nom de son temps
dans le chapeau pour cette course oui
oui c'est pas garanti non plus ça sera
pas un des dix mois facile
nécessairement pour le npd merci
beaucoup camille guy roy avec le npd et
allons voir dans le camp du vainqueur
d'oxford matthieu simard c'est l'endroit
où ça a fêté ce soir on me dit que tous
les ministres du gouvernement fortes
sont réélus monsieur ford également qui
compte
une plus grande équipe c'est vraiment un
triomphe sur toute la ligne
c'est le l'endroit le parti de la
victoire mathieu mais je vous dirais que
la fête est déjà terminée si on est déjà
en train de vente propre tête vont
travailler la salle voilà on nettoie la
salle on ramasse leslie chaises et tout
le monde est parti mais geste que c'est
le scénario de rêve qui s'est réalisé
aujourd'hui pour les
progressistes-conservateurs je regarde
le compteur à l'écran on est rendu à 83
sièges en ce moment on peut pratiquement
parler d'une super majorité pour les
progressistes-conservateurs donc
assurément ça a fait plaisir à bien des
gens ici au quartier général des
progressistes conservateurs y avait
beaucoup de sourires sur les visages des
gens pour revenir au discours de doctor
son discours de victoire est évidemment
aussi attendait c'était à saveur
économique on a parlé de création
d'emplois monsieur fall a pratiquement
promis un emploi pour tous les ontariens
qui le voulaient notamment des emplois
dans nord avec avec l'exploitation du
cercle de feu il a aussi parlé de son
équipe géniale son équipe qui dit il a
cogné à environ 3 millions de portes au
cours des quatre dernières semaines et
selon lui ça fait la différence et
monsieur fall qui a aussi lancé un appel
à l'unité vous savez il a dit mon parti
le parti progressiste conservateur on
est maintenant une coalition des
lecteurs et que vous soyez travailleurs
de l'automobile dans la région de
windsor qui avant voter pour les
néo-démocrates que vous soyez un
électeur qui est aux élections fédérales
vote libéral bien vous pouvez vous
retrouver dans mon parti donc c'est le
message d'unité qu'il a voulu lancer ce
soir aux ontariens et
les résultats de ce soir c'est aussi la
preuve que sa stratégie de réélection a
fonctionné que son message était clair
il s'est présenté comme le parti qui
faisait avancer les dossiers qui faisait
bouger les choses je suis simplement
avec le slogan what galette donne c'est
à dire nous allons accomplir des choses
est et tout au long de cette campagne
monsieur fau de rappelons le il s'est
présenté comme un homme d'action comme
un homme qui se rouler les manches plus
souvent qu'autrement on l'a vu avec un
casque de construction sur la tête
entouré de travailleurs dans des usines
donc il a présenté cette image de goût
moment qu'ils allaient faire avancer les
dossiers qui ne ferait pas du sur place
clairement ça à charmer les électeurs ce
soir est la bonne nouvelle pour mesures
fortes et qu'il a maintenant quatre
années devant lui pour poursuivre les
chantiers pour poursuivre les dossiers
qu'il avait amorcé lors de son premier
mandat et avec tous ces projets qui nous
promet d'autoroute d'hôpitaux et cetera
il râle beaucoup d'occasions de remettre
sur son casque de construction dans les
prochaines années merci beaucoup
monsieur simard chez les conservateurs
ce soir vous en prie d'ailleurs au
courant de la campagne monsieur fort
lorsqu'il annonçait ces événements du
lent mais c'était simplement écrit on
veut une annonce pour accomplir des
choses on savait vraiment jamais
vraiment précisément c'était quoi
c'était sa stratégie de campagne on a eu
des nouvelles du premier ministre du
québec françois legault tout à l'heure
philippe qui félicitait monsieur x 10
nouvelles d'ottawa oui justin trudeau au
premier ministre canadien qui qui dit
dans son gazouillis je félicite le
premier ministre d'oxford pour sa
réélection j'ai hâte de poursuivre notre
collaboration est de continuer à livrer
des résultats pour les ontariens et pour
tous les canadiens je vous invite à
faire un dernier tour de piste non
invasive regard la carte parce que c'est
quand même cette circonscription qui ont
été ramassés par les progressistes
conservateurs et ça se voit sur la carte
on n'a qu'à regarder dans la grande
région de toronto le lac ou rendu 9,05
c'est vraiment impressionnant on a raflé
ces circonscriptions là y'a juste oshawa
ici où on n'a pas été en mesure ça a été
une course très bon on n'a pas été en
mesure d'aller récupérer cette
circonscription là quand même des gains
haussière à toronto avec que la
circonscription du yorkshire weston sud
remportée par son oeuvre michael ford
allons maintenant dans le sud ouest de
l'ontario qui a été également très
déterminant pour les
progressistes-conservateurs avec des
gains de regain dans la région de
windsor un autre surprise peut-être ce
soir c'est l'ajout de sept
circonscriptions créées par des meneurs
phuc donc une nouvelle quand une
nouvelle députée indépendante est rare
de voir en ontario
de ce que je me rappelle jean fait je
n'ai jamais vu une députée indépendante
élue donc 195 1980 voilà donc c'était il
ya très très longtemps dans l'est
ontarien on a vu également des on
ramasse la région de kingston du côté
des libéraux et puis les néo démocrates
sont parvenus à les ramasser la halle
ottawa ouest nepean inquiet quand même
une circonscription important et petit
coup d'oeil peut-être dans le nord de
l'ontario ya maintenant une tache bleue
dans le orange est habituel this week
end et hb hoyaux lui voit donc si on
regarde voici la carte en 2018 donc les
libéraux le rouge c'est complètement
rayé du nord de l'ontario il ya une
tache bleue évidemment une grosse grosse
perte on perd un canon lourd avec que
gilles bisson du côté des néo-démocrates
et puis on a également créé un dingue du
côté de cela nos vies a dit cochrane
pour les progressistes conservateurs
voilà merci beaucoup fait les parts
revenant ce message de justin trudeau
ont discuté tout à leur natasha
geneviève de ce que voulait de ce sable
aisée pour la suite des choses donc on
poursuit dans la même direction ce
rapprochement entre les deux provinces
même si les affiliations politiques sont
pas les mêmes et monsieur trudeau a sans
doute m'aider monsieur x il en faisant
une entente avec le npd
cette fameuse entente où les libéraux
ont dit oui on va donner plus de
programmes sociaux et s'ils arrivent en
ontario maintenant une bonne partie de
ces nouveaux programmes vont être
financés par le palier fédéral donc là
le plan provincial plus s'occuper
d'autre chose monsieur faure doit
clairement compris le message et lui va
s'occuper d'économie d'infrastructures
est sans doute celui aussi de collaborer
avec monsieur trudeau définitivement
mais oui ça vote in dynamique différente
de ce qu'on avait vu il ya quatre ans
justement il ya peut-être des électeurs
qui se sont dit ça me sert à rien de
voter npd ou libérale de toute façon le
fédéral va me donner ses programmes
longs donc pourquoi pas voté pour la
continuité pour monsieur fruits parlant
de électeurs qui se disent ça vaut
peut-être pas la peine d'aller voter on
n'a pas tous les chiffres mais c'est pas
son un portrait du taux de participation
me disais tout à l'heure qu'on était
légèrement au dessus des 40 %
41,9 carte est ce que ça donne le 46
41,6 pour ça et on est largement en
dessous des 50 8% ça va continuer de
grimper un peu il ya pas tous les votes
de compter le mais quand même thématique
votre lecture là tu sais c'est quand
même triste le taux de participation le
plus bas dans l'histoire de l'ontario
c'était 48,2 pour cent leurs seuils
d'âge 10 a obtenu sa minorité en 2011 là
on est en dessous de tout ça c'est quand
même impressionnant
comment on analyse ça d'avoir bon ce
sont les plus vieux qui vont voter
d'habitude les plus vieux vote pour les
conservateurs
il ya aucun parti visiter beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui que ce sont dix savent
aussi jouer d'avant ça vaut pas la peine
d'aller également le fait que les
sondages et pas du tout bougé tout le
long de la campagne mais j'en parlais
avec mon coiffeur plutôt tantôt et lui
il n'était pas allé voter parce qu'il me
dit écoute et vendent donc fois gagné de
toute manière
également je pense que les gens ont
connu beaucoup de bouleversements avant
les deux dernières années la pandémie
les manifestations de camionneurs les
fusillades aux états unis l'ukraine et
je pense que les gens veulent de la
stabilité en ce moment les veulent pas
de changement on vient d'avoir deux
élections fédérales qui se boit un coup
sur coup ça aussi ça le jouet un taux de
participation faible comme ça ça veut
pas dire que les gens ne s'intéressent
pas à la politique ça peut aussi des peu
importe quel parti est au pouvoir
ça changera rien dans les médias dans ma
vie c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu avec le
coup de lévigny je trouve que tous les
partis je prends tous les partis
confondus peut-être à l'exception du
parti vert ont manqué d'imagination et
d'inspiration
dans cette campagne s'inscrit comme un
miroir qui doit se retourner vers les
policiers où il ya des gens qui vont pas
voter mais optez aussi des partis qui
réussissent pas à intéresser la
population effectivement et je pense que
vraiment une introspection affaires et
en se disant également
le thème c'était le coût de la vie
puisque on nous promettait c'était de
créer des emplois c'est comme si les
parties étant décalé avec les besoins
des ontariens est ce que quelque chose
qui touche plus les gens ce moment que
le coût de la vie il me semble que
c'était le sujet car on n'est pas
habitué
réfléchir à ce problème là alors on ne
peut pas arriver toujours l'âme avec une
plateforme qui s'occupe que ça intéresse
à l'inflation on ne sait pas quoi faire
ça fait 20 ans qu'on s'occupe d'eux de
perte d'emploi qui lobait c'est le
contraire on a des emplois mais honda
d'inflation alors on n'a pas été assez
rapides on n'a pas été créatifs
imaginatifs puis peut-être aussi un peu
détaché du terrain c'est bon d'être
forcé à aller parler avec les électeurs
puis peut-être qu'on le fait pas assez
alors oui le miroir les transactions qui
vont être nécessaires je pense que
d'oxford s'est approprié cet enjeu la de
l'abordabilité assez tôt avant même la
campagne avec un une promesse en
particulier le remboursement des frais
de vignes et les partis d'opposition
avaient ridiculisé cette proposition
lundi à écouter et jeudis vous allez
acheter des votes mais c'est quand même
un chèque qui est rentré dans la poche
de centaines de milliers d'ontariens
tout juste avant l'élection est dans la
poche de qui des automobilistes
l'électorat que cibler monsieur ford
alors là ça sera complètement coupé
l'herbe sous le pied des autres partis
je crois et c'est une réflexion à avoir
lorsqu'il n'ya même pas la moitié des
gens qui vont qui vont voter le site un
peu triste pour la ville ces deux oui
c'est triste et défonce assoit un peu
sur ses lauriers en disant oui ce qu'on
voit dans d'autres pays ça nous arrivera
pas mais faudrait faire attention c'est
important c'est quand même une fois tous
les quatre ans avec ce qui se passe en
ukraine et l'ukrainien qui se braquent
pour leur démocratie c'est drôle j'ai
entendu quelqu'un dire exactement la
même chose tout à l'heure en ukraine y
ait des gens qui se battraient pour
pouvoir aller voter aujourd'hui et nous
voilà il ya la moitié des otaries et les
plus qu'ils ne sont pas allés voter
aujourd'hui vîmes dans les dix journées
de vote par anticipation avait doublé le
nombre de journées ça fonctionne et
quelque peu pour le vote par
anticipation bref petit tableau pour
vous montrons parler de monsieur fall
qui va pouvoir compter sur son équipe
complète ça c'est le conseil des
ministres de d'oxford à la dissolution
de l'assemblée législative et tous ces
visages de toutes les personnes que vous
voyez ont été réélus peut-être un petit
nombre m'indique doc dany voilà c'est
moi tout à fait terminée d'arrêt il est
en avance
contre le
le maire de bari qui bien connu me dit
monsieur d'harmonie et un est en avance
pour l'instant d'attaché vous connaissez
tous chemins le common double fond de
votre poche là on pourrait peut-être
occupé les mêmes fonctions mais écoutez
moi je pense que a menti mcnaughton le
ministre du travail vaut probablement
occupé la même fonction peut-être qu'il
va avoir une promotion pour une tape
dans le dos là parce que c'est lui
vraiment qui a été l'architecte de cette
stratégie d'aller séduire les
travailleurs très tôt il est allé faire
des relations avec les syndicats de la
construction qui sont venus appuyer dr
par la suite à donner de l'argent pour
les métiers spécialisés et clairement
que ça a fonctionné
alors si ce qui conclut cette soirée des
élections en ontario je veux saluer mes
collègues en studio et russes un gars au
résultat philippe de montignac carte
interactive jeudi at elle dit l'attaché
mec de m si beaucoup d'avoir été là avec
nous on vous rappelle radio canada qui a
confirmé très tôt ce soir la réélection
du gouvernement de d'oxford à la tête
d'un gouvernement majoritaire pour les
quatre prochaines années ce match on
adore direct de temps ont donc merci à
toute l'équipe a régit également
excellent fêtes soirée agréable
[Musique]
là